You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
你知道的，你的眼睛承受了很大的压力。每天阅读、处于昏暗光线中、看屏幕时间太长，这种情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光直射眼睛。甚至夜间开车也会导致眼睛疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛承受了很大的负荷。因此，通过定期视力检查来照顾它们并监测其健康状况非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行视力检查（99 美元起），检查眼睛健康，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段检测出眼部和健康状况。若要寻找离您最近的分店并预约含
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind. behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello there. Hi there. How's it going? It's good, you know. I'm cozy. We're at home today. We are recording from home like the olden days. The olden times. I'm wrapped up in a blanket because my closet doesn't get any heat. I have on my cozy slippers that I love. We're cozy guys. It's going to be a cozy kind of day. It really is.
OCT 扫描且 99 美元起的视力检查，请访问 specsavers.ca。视力检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能因分店而异。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了这个终极版《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事。我们是“办公室女士”6.0 版。大家好。嗨。最近怎么样？挺好的，你知道的。我很舒服。我们今天在家。我们像以前一样在家录音。老时光。我裹着一条毯子，因为我的衣帽间没有暖气。我穿着我最喜欢的舒适拖鞋。我们很舒服，各位。这将会是舒适的一天。真的。
Today, we're going to be breaking down another webisode. We're breaking down the webisode called The Podcast. This is layered. We're doing a podcast about an episode called The Podcast. So this was a three-part series, and, you know, it's all about the character Gabe. It's really centered on him as he tries to start a podcast for the Sabre website. Yes. And we thought, after we break down this webisode, it might be fun for us to talk a little bit about how we started Office Ladies. Yeah. So this is something we've never played for you guys before and you all that have been listening from the very beginning. It's our, well, it's our version of our pilot, right? Jenna, it's our Office Ladies pilot. Yeah, Gabe is going to be making his podcast pilot in the webisode and
今天，我们要剖析另一集网络剧集。我们要剖析的那集网络剧集叫做《播客》。这很有层叠感。我们在做一个关于一集名为《播客》的剧集的播客。所以这是一个三部曲系列，你知道的，内容完全围绕着盖布这个角色。它真正以他为中心，讲述了他试图为赛博网站创办一个播客的故事。是的。我们觉得，在剖析完这集网络剧集后，我们聊聊当初是如何创办《办公室女士》的，可能会很有趣。是的。所以这是我们以前从未向你们播放过的内容，特别是那些从一开始就一直在收听的听众。这是我们的，嗯，我们的试播集版本，对吧？珍娜，这是我们的《办公室女士》试播集。是的，盖布将在网络剧集中制作他的播客试播集，
we thought maybe we should share the Office Ladies pilot with you all. And we also hold some podcast-related fan questions from our digital mailbag, and we're going to read those. So it's podcast Paloosa today on Office Ladies. Podcast Paloza. I like it. You like that? I do. But to kick things off, here are some stats about the podcast web episode.
我们觉得也许应该与大家分享《办公室女士》的试播集。此外，我们数字邮箱里还积压了一些与播客相关的粉丝提问，我们将宣读这些问题。所以今天是《办公室女士》的播客狂欢节。播客狂欢节。我喜欢。你喜欢这个？我喜欢。但在开始之前，这里有一些关于播客网络剧集的统计数据。
My lady loves some stats. I do. Stats, stats, stats, stats, stats, stats. That's your song. Is that my clubbing song? Would I dance to that in the club? Not two shots, shots. Stats, stat, stats.
我的女神最喜欢统计数据了。没错。统计数据、统计数据、统计数据、统计数据、统计数据。这是你的歌。那是我的夜店嗨曲吗？我会在夜店里随着这个跳舞吗？不是“干杯、干杯”（shots、shots），而是“统计、统、统计”（stats、stat、stats）。
Stats, stat, stat, stat. I can see it. I can see it. This webisode was released in January 2011 during the seventh season of The Office. It was directed by one of our writers, Charlie Grandy. And like Angela said earlier, it was a three-part series. And they were written by Kelly Hannan, Jonathan Hughes, and Mary Wall. Kelly Hannan was our writer's PA, so she was their production assistant.
统计、统、统、统计。我能想象出来。我能想象出来。这集网络剧集于 2011 年 1 月首播，当时正值《办公室》第七季。它由我们的编剧之一查理·格兰迪执导。正如安吉拉刚才所说，这是一个三部曲系列。它们由凯利·哈南、乔纳森·休斯和玛丽·沃尔编剧。凯利·哈南当时是我们编剧团队的制片助理。
Jonathan Hughes was one of our writer's assistants, and Mary Wall was a producer's assistant. And these webisodes were a really cool way for them to break out of those roles and get to create content. Yeah, you know, Jenna, when we started breaking down the webisodes, I got this great email from Karen Angelo. She worked at NBC when we were launching all of these webisodes, and we traded messaging. just back and forth, and I wanted to share this email she sent. It's about how we started a digital writers program. And really, we were, well, Carol said we were pioneers. I love it. Again, the web episodes were bringing new things to the industry. Okay, here's what Carol wrote in her email to me. She said, Angela, I listened to subtle sexuality on my drive to work this morning. It brought
乔纳森·休斯是我们的编剧助理之一，玛丽·沃尔则是一位制片人助理。这些网络剧集对他们来说是一个非常酷的途径，可以突破这些角色限制并开始创作内容。对啊，你知道吗，珍娜，当我们开始剖析这些网络剧集时，我收到了凯伦·安杰洛发来的一封很棒的邮件。当我们在推出所有这些网络剧集时，她在 NBC 工作，我们来来回回发了很多信息，我想分享她发来的这封邮件。内容是关于我们如何发起数字编剧计划的。而且说实话，我们，嗯，卡罗尔说我们是先驱。我太喜欢了。再次说明，这些网络剧集为这个行业带来了新事物。好吧，这是卡罗尔在邮件中对我说的话。她说，安吉拉，我今天早上开车上班时听了《潜意识纯洁性》。这带回了
back so many great memories, as did the accountant's episode. Lady, first of all, I just love that Carol is listening to our podcast on her drive to work. Love it. Love it. Made me so happy. Carol was just so much fun to work with. And I love that our podcast brought us back together. She goes on to say, I was in so many meetings with Greg Daniels and other NBC executives and the sales team trying to sell the idea of these webisodes and get sponsors to sponsor them.
许多美好的回忆，《会计师》那一集也是如此。天哪，首先，我只是很高兴卡罗尔在开车上班的路上听我们的播客。太棒了。太棒了。这让我非常开心。和卡罗尔一起工作总是那么开心。而且我很高兴我们的播客让我们重新聚在了一起。接着她写道，我和格雷格·丹尼尔斯、其他 NBC 高管以及销售团队开过很多次会，试图推销这些网络剧集的想法，并寻找赞助商来赞助它们。
She said, here's my favorite part, lady. She said, Our digital writer program with your writer's assistance was the first of its kind and as far as I know, the only one of its kind. She said she used the success
她说，这是我最喜欢的部分，亲爱的。她说，我们与你们的编剧助理共同开展的数字编剧计划是同类计划中的首创，据我所知，也是唯一的一个。她说她利用《办公室》数字内容的成功
of the Office Digital content to pitch and create online series for Parks and Rec, 30 Rock, Heroes, Parenthood, and she said a ton of shows we probably never even heard of. Wow. She goes on to say
来推销并创建了《公园与游憩》、《我本疯狂》、《英雄》、《为人父母》的线上剧集，她说还有一大堆我们可能听都没听过的节目。哇。她接着说，
after the success of the accountants and the subsequent writer's strike. She literally wrote, ahem, a-ham. Okay. That was her. That was her. She said she worked with Greg and NBC to achieve a few goals. Number one, give the junior writers identified by the showrunners a chance to showcase their writing skills. Number two, compensate them for writing additional digital content
在《会计师》取得成功以及随后的编剧罢工之后。她原话写道，咳咳，啊哈。好吧。那是她。那是她。她说她与格雷格和 NBC 合作实现了几个目标。第一，让剧集运作人认可的年轻编剧有机会展示他们的写作才华。第二，全年在
throughout the year. Number three, collaborate directly with the show creators on creative concepts outside of the normal episodes. Number four, showcase supporting cast and give talent and our other show production staff a chance to write and direct if they were interested, like Mindy and Charlie, Jen Salada. It was really a place where people could create in a way that they couldn't normally on the regular episodes. That is so cool. The webisodes really were like the first time that some people directed, like Kelly Cantley. Like Randall Einhorn. Yeah.
创作额外的数字内容时给予他们报酬。第三，直接与剧集创作者合作，探讨常规剧集之外的创意概念。第四，展示配角阵容，并给有兴趣的演员以及其他剧集制作人员提供写作和导演的机会，比如明迪、查理和珍·萨拉达。这真的是一个让人们能够以常规剧集无法实现的方式进行创作的地方。这太酷了。网络剧集确实就像某些人第一次执导的机会，比如凯利·坎特利。比如兰德尔·艾因霍恩。对啊。
That was their first time directing for the show. And now those people are directors. Yeah. It was almost like an apprentice program for some of the aspiring writers and for people to work outside of their normal roles on the show. Exactly. Carol said that they enlisted the junior writers or writers assistants and they would come to their weekly NBC digital meetings. They would collaborate with the NBC digital team on future episodes and different things. they could tie webisodes too. They also strategically tried to target times of the year when the
那是他们第一次为该剧执导。而现在，这些人都是导演了。是的。对于一些有抱负的编剧以及希望在剧中常规角色之外工作的人来说，这几乎就像是一个学徒计划。没错。卡罗尔说，他们招募了年轻编剧或编剧助理，他们会参加每周的 NBC 数字会议。他们将与 NBC 数字团队合作开发未来的剧集以及网络剧集可以与之结合的不同事物。他们还战略性地试图瞄准一年中的某些时段，让
webisodes would keep the audience going and engaged. For example, while we were on hiatus or if the show was interrupted by like the Winter Olympics, what could the audience still find that was new and original content? Smart. And Carol answers a fan question, Jenna. No kidding. What's that? She says, I think one of your listeners had a great question as to why if Aaron and Kelly had a girl group, why was it never referenced on the linear show? Carol said they were always trying to pitch these website and then original broadcast airing crossovers, but the only time it actually happened for them was with Parks and Recreation. So the show was going to be shooting at the Grand Canyon during season four, and there was a B story where April and Andy are checking an item off Andy's
网络剧集能让观众保持关注并保持参与度。例如，当我们在播出间隙休息时，或者如果节目被诸如冬季奥运会之类的活动打断时，观众还能找到什么新鲜且原创的内容呢？很聪明。而且卡罗尔回答了一个粉丝的问题，珍娜。真的吗？是什么？她说，我想你们的一位听众提出了一个很好的问题，既然艾琳和凯利有一个女子组合，为什么在正片中从未提及过？卡罗尔说，他们总是试图推销这些网络剧集和原创电视广播播出的联动，但唯一真正实现的一次是与《公园与游憩》。当时该剧准备在第四季时前往大峡谷拍摄，其中有一条 B 线剧情是阿普里尔和安迪去完成安迪遗愿清单上的一项内容，他们通过一个关于他们在去大峡谷途中发生的事情的数字系列扩展了这条故事线。但他们从未能为我们的节目做到这一点，不过他们确实为《公园与游憩》做到了。但卡罗尔说，你们真的是先驱。她说，我珍藏着我那张签名的“三楼”海报，它目前挂在我的办公室里。直到今天，她已经不在 NBC 工作了。她现在是福克斯喜剧和动画创意广告部门的副总裁。真棒，卡罗尔，但我很喜欢《办公室》网络剧集的零星片段直到今天依然挂在她的办公室里。是的，这太酷了。我们还没开始剖析“三楼”呢。对，还没呢。不过话说回来，这些信息不是很棒吗？谢谢你，卡罗尔。
bucket list, and they extended that story through a digital series about what happened to them on the way to the Grand Canyon. But they never got to do that for our show, but they did get to do it for Parks and Rec. But Carol said, you guys truly were the pioneers. And she said, I cherish my signed third floor poster, which currently hangs in my office. Still to this day, she doesn't work for NBC anymore. She now is the vice president of comedy and animation creative advertising at Fox. Way to go, Carol, but I love that a little piece of the office webisodes is in her office still today. Yes, that's very cool. We haven't broken down the third floor yet. No, we haven't. But anyway, wasn't that great information? Thank you, Carol.
谢谢你，卡罗尔。那么，安吉拉，我没记错的话，你、布莱恩和奥斯卡曾写过一集网络剧集，但遗憾的是最终没有被制作出来？是的，我们写过。当时我们实际上在和保罗·利伯斯坦来来回回地交流意见，他们也一直在为我们的网络剧集系列寻找档期。但由于他们已经答应了其他编剧助理的一堆积压网络剧集。所以我们有点排在名单的底部，等轮到我们的时候，他们已经停止制作网络剧集了。所以我们基本上就错过了。但我们在写作时玩得很开心，而且本来是由布莱恩来执导的。你觉得，比如，你还能找到剧本吗？我找得到。我确实还留着……我们应该，我们应该什么时候读一下它吗？也许吧。我们应该让
Thank you, Carol. Now, Angela, am I correct that you, Brian, and Oscar wrote a webisode that unfortunately did not end up being produced? Yeah, we did. We actually were trading like notes with Paul Lieberstein at the time, and then they were trying to find a slot for us to have our webisode series. But there was this backlog of webisodes they had already promised to other writers' assistants. So we were sort of like towards the bottom of the list, and by the time they got to us, they had stopped making the webisodes. So we kind of just missed out on it. But we had a lot of fun writing them, and Brian was going to direct them. Do you think, like, could you, do you still have the script? I do. I do still have... Should we, should we like read it sometime? Maybe. Should we get
布莱恩和奥斯卡来做客，在《办公室女士》上读一读你们写的网络剧集吗？那会超级有趣的。对，我很乐意。我很想听听看。好吧，我去问问他们。我不记得讲的是什么了。我知道你当时把它给我看过了，我记得它真的很好笑，但我不记得它的情节了。所以我必须回翻一下我的数字杂物堆，但我保留了所有东西。我还记得我们和保罗一起进行的头脑风暴笔记会议。我记得我们最终决定写一集圣帕特里克节的网络剧集。对。什么？那是一个四部分组成的。我记得，我觉得是四部分。而且我记得凯文在圣帕特里克节游行中迷路了。所以我记得从后勤角度来说，我们必须弄清楚如何拍摄这些内容同时还要控制预算。这可能也是它被压到名单底下的原因，因为我们的预算相当大。不过是的，我依然留着它们。我觉得你需要把这些翻出来。我觉得我们需要和奥斯卡以及布莱恩开启一个短信群聊，看看大家的空闲时间。来朗读我们写的圣帕特里克节网络剧集，那会非常有趣的。是的。嗯，我很喜欢听关于那个编剧计划的事。而且我很高兴我们的节目是帮助人们崭露头角的一部分
Brian and Oscar to come in and read your webisode on office ladies? That would be so much fun. Yeah, I would love that. I would love to hear it. Okay, I'll ask them. I can't remember what it's about. I know you gave it to me at the time to read it and I remember it was really funny, but I don't remember the plot of it. So I will have to go back in my digital clutter, but I have all of it. And I remember I even have our brainstorming note sessions that we had with Paul. And I remember we landed on us writing a St. Patrick's Day webisode. Yeah. What? It was a four part. I believe, I think it was four parts. And I think Kevin gets lost in the St. Patrick's Day parade. So I remember a logistically, we had to figure out how to film these and then stay on budget. That might be also why it got pushed to the bottom of the list, because ours was a pretty big budget. But yeah, I still have them. I think you need to dig these out. And I think we need to start a text chain with Oscar and Brian and see what everyone's avails are. To read the St. Patrick's Day web episodes, we wrote, that would be so fun. Yes. Well, I love hearing about that writer's program. And I love that our show was part of something that was helping people break.
像那样。我觉得这真的很酷。我知道。我很高兴，你知道的，我们的节目在许多方面、许多平台上都是先驱。好了，安吉，为了圆满完成开场白，我想我可以宣读两封来自我们数字邮箱的、与播客有关的信件。好的。第一封来自费城的林赛·M，她说，不是一个问题，更像是一个 FYI。哦，为了让你知悉。嗯哼。为什么我为自己知道 FYI 是什么而感到如此自豪？为什么我这么，就这没什么好吹嘘的。大家都知道 FYI 是什么，但我显然是那么的高兴，以至于我想——我必须把它说出来。
out like that. I think that's really cool. I know. I love that, you know, our show was a pioneer in many ways in many platforms. Well, now, Ange, to round out our top of show, I thought I could read two letters from our digital mailbag that are podcast related. Okay. The first one is from Lindsay M in Philadelphia, who said, not a question, but more of an FYI. Oh, for your information. Mm-hmm. Why am I so proud that I know what FYI is? Why am I so, like, that's nothing to brag about. Everybody knows what FYI is, but I clearly was so tickled that I was like, I had to say it.
好吧，你知道吗？这可能算是一种炫耀，因为她要告诉我们一些我们不知道其含义的事情。哦，好吧。她认为我们应该了解的事情。林赛说，你们需要停止说“潜入他们的私信”（slid into their DMs）。它不是你们想的那种意思。它不意味着你只是找到了他们。我在网上找到了你，然后我突然出现来跟你聊天。
Well, you know what? It might be a good flex because she's going to tell us about something that we don't know the meaning of. Oh, okay. That she thinks we should be aware of. Lindsay said, you need to stop saying, quote, slid into their DMs. It does not mean what you think it means. It doesn't mean like you just found them. I found you online and I'm popping in here to talk to you.
不是吗？不是吗？显然不是，亲爱的。那是什么意思？他说，根据 dictionary.com 的解释，它的意思是巧妙而酷炫地给社交媒体上的某人发送私信，通常出于浪漫的目的。当你潜入某人的私信时，你发消息给他们是希望收到裸照、约炮或是确立恋爱关系。什么？
No. Was it? No, apparently not, lady. What's it mean? He said, according to dictionary.com, it means sending someone a direct message on social media slickly and coolly, often for romantic purposes. When you slide into someone's DMs, you, are messaging them in hopes to receive either nudes, a hookup, or a relationship. What?
根据城市词典（Urban Dictionary）的解释，它的意思是你在脸书、照片墙或推特上开启私信链。当你潜入某人的私信时，是抱着能发生性关系的希望。林赛说，这就是一次约炮电话。请不要再说什么你正在潜入别人的私信了。哦，我们说过很多次了。听着，我知道那是那个意思，但我以为它也仅仅意味着，我在主动联系聊天。我以为它，就像，有时它是指约炮电话，但我以为有时它只是意味着，嘿，你好呀。是的，我不知道。
And according to Urban Dictionary, it means when you start a direct message chain on Facebook, Instagram, or Twitter, when you slide into someone's DMs, it's with the hopes of booty. It's a booty call, Lindsay said. Please stop saying you're sliding into people's DMs. Oh, we've said it a lot. Listen, I knew that it meant that, but I thought it also meant just, I'm reaching out to chat. I thought it, like, sometimes it means booty call, but I thought sometimes it meant just like, hey, there. Yeah, I didn't know.
它一直意味着，像，是的，我想要，你知道的，性爱和裸照之类的事情。我以为它有更广泛的含义。我要说的是这个。什么？我不会停止说这句话的。真的吗？但我得，不。不。
It always meant like, like, yeah, I want, you know, booty and nudie things. I thought it had more of a universal meaning. Here's what I'm going to say. What? I'm not going to stop saying it. Really? But I have to no. No.
不。你只是因为你觉得。我还要继续潜入别人的私信。我会的。我潜入了丹妮·戈登的私信，现在我们要邀请她上播客了。丹妮·戈登，著名的导演。她要来我们的播客聊聊她在《办公室》的经历。你还能怎么说？
No. You're just because you're like. I'm going to keep sliding into people's DMs. I am. I slid into Denny Gordon's DMs and now we're going to have her on the pod. Denny Gordon, famous director. She's coming on the pod to talk to us about her time on the office. How else do you say it?
我想你可以直接说我私信（DM'd）她了。我私信了她。是的。听起来没那么有趣。确实没有。我宁愿“滑”进去（slide in）。我们也可以自己编一个。比如我们可以说我侧滑进了她的私信。
I guess you could just say I DM'd her. I DM'd her. Yeah. It doesn't sound as fun. It doesn't. I'd rather slide in. We could make up our own. Like we could say I skid it into her DMs.
我侧手翻进了她的私信。对。我做了一个前滚翻。前滚翻。我不知道。你知道吗？因为我能，我知道。我的前滚翻会有多慢，看起来会有多不性感。
I cartwheeled into her DMs. Yeah. I did a forward roll. A forward roll. I don't know. You know what? Because I could just, I know. how slowly my forward roll would be and how unsexy it would look.
好吧，等我翻到那里，我的脖子肯定已经扭伤了。哦，是的。你会扭伤背部的。别扭伤了背。滑进某人的私信。不，我需要滑进去。不，你需要滑进去。其实，我真的只需要溜达进去。
Well, by the time I got there, my neck would be all out of whack. Oh, yeah. You throw your back out. Don't throw your back out. Into someone's DMs. No, I need to slide in. No, you need to slide in. Actually, I really just need to stroll in.
这个，我喜欢。这是最安全的方式。我溜达进了他们的私信。这就是我们要说的话。搞定。我喜欢。我们找到了。听起来比“滑”进去好多了，滑进去听起来有点……
That's, I like this. That's the safest way. I strolled into their DMs. That's what we're going to say. Done. I like it. We found it. It sounds better than skid it in, too.
滑进去，我不太喜欢。听起来好像你要擦伤膝盖什么的。溜达进去。当你在某处溜达时，没有人会受伤。我们花了一点时间，但我们找到了。我们现在要溜达进别人的私信了。谢谢你，林赛。
That sounds a bit. Skid it I don't like. Sounds like you're going to scrape your knee or something. Strolling in. No one's getting hurt when you stroll in somewhere. It took us a while, but we found it. We're strolling into people's DMs now. Thank you, Lindsay.
谢谢你，林赛。最后，来自纽约州伊萨卡的萨姆·埃尔说，祝贺你们完成你们那个精彩播客的剧集系列，很高兴你们能继续把快乐传递下去。我们是袖珍强盗（Pocket Bandits）。我们是一个立足于纽约州中部、由丹麦裔和美裔组成的乐器放克摇滚三人组，三个朋友，也是长期的音乐合作伙伴，参加过很多地方演出，但过去也曾分别与伊凡塞斯、凯尔特雷霆、汉森等乐队同台演出，
Thank you, Lindsay. And now finally, Sam Elle and Ithaca, New York said, congratulations on completing the series on your wonderful podcast, and so glad you'll be keeping the fun going. We are pocket bandits. We're a Danish-American instrumental funk rock trio based in central New York state, three friends and longtime musical collaborators who play a lot of local gigs, but have separately played shows with bands like Evanescence, Celtic Thunder, Hanson,
还有多年来的许多其他乐队。这些可都是大牌。我知道。我喜欢汉森。我喜欢伊凡塞斯。萨姆·埃尔接着说，我们喜欢《办公室》。我们实际上在以“拯救强盗”（Save Bandit）的名义进行第一场演出之前，才意识到互联网上已经有一堆乐队使用这个名字了，所以我们成了“袖珍强盗”。
and a whole host of others over the years. Those are some big names. I know. I love Hansen. I like Evanescence. Sam Elle goes on to say, we love The Office. we actually played our first show under the name Save Bandit before we realized there were a bunch of bands on the internet that have already used the name so we became Pocket Bandits.
并且我们将对该剧集的引用保留在我们的某些歌曲标题中。接下来这部分非常温馨。为了纪念你们开始播客的“第二杯”环节，因为各位，那是，你知道的，每周一我们都会重新播放重温集锦。对。我们称之为“第二杯”。我们在开头放一些小花絮，一些额外的八卦。是的，每周一。
And we stuck to referencing the show in some of our song titles. And here's the part that's so sweet. In honor of you starting the second drink portion of your podcast, because everyone, that's, you know, every Monday we rerun the rewatch in order. Right. And we call it second drink. And we put little tidbits at the top, little extra tidbits. Yeah, every Monday.
每周一。萨姆说，我们想分享我们的新歌《第二杯》。啊。以防它能博得你们俩以及播客听众的一笑，希望它今天能带给你们一点快乐。所以我截取了一段音频剪辑。这是袖珍强盗乐队演奏他们的歌曲《第二杯》。非常好听，对吧？是的。
Every Monday. Sam said, we want to share our new song, Second Drink. Aw. In case it might get a grin out of y'all and maybe the podcast listeners, too, hope it brings you a little joy today. So I grabbed an audio clip. This is Pocket Bandits playing their song Second Drink. Very nice, right? Yeah.
每周一。萨姆说，我们想分享我们的新歌《第二杯》。啊。以防它能让你们所有人会心一笑，也许还有播客听众，希望它今天能给你带来一点快乐。所以我抓取了一段音频。这是Pocket Bandits在演奏他们的歌曲《第二杯》。非常好听，对吧？是的。
That's some funk rock. Yeah. I hear it. I do too. You know, I'm big on guitar riffs right now. I'm enjoying that guitar. And that's Simon on drums, Samuel on organ and bass keys, and Joe on guitar. Great job.
真是首放克摇滚。是的。我听出来了。我也是。你知道的，我最近对吉他华彩情有独钟。我很喜欢那段吉他。打鼓的是西蒙，管风琴和低音键盘是塞缪尔，吉他是乔。干得好。
Yes, I loved it. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we will break down the podcast episodes. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. but maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine.
是的，我很喜欢。好了，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？等我们回来后，我们会剖析播客剧集。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，新年新气象并不意味着你必须脱胎换骨。但也许你想卸下一些负担，变得更清醒。不是变成一个全新的人，而是也许你想更加专注于核心。你想精进自我。对。我喜欢这个。精进。
Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things.
嗯，心理咨询可以帮助你更轻松地找出是什么让你感到沉重，是什么在拖你的后腿。你能更好地理解自己的人际关系、动机和情绪。我正试图放下对小事的焦虑。嗯。因为那些琐事真的会积少成多。嗯。而且一切都会好起来的。嗯，你可能需要有人帮忙辨别什么是小事，什么是大事。
BetterHelp therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, H-E-L-P. com slash office ladies. Well, we are back, and the webisodes, the podcast, the first one is called Gabe's podcast.
BetterHelp 的咨询师可以帮到你。BetterHelp 拥有超过 3 万名咨询师，是全球最大的在线心理咨询平台，已为全球超过 500 万人服务。BetterHelp让你能轻而易举地在网上匹配到合格的咨询师。登录 betterhelp.com/officeladies 注册即可享受九折优惠。网址是 betterhelp.com/officeladies。好了，我们回来了，网络剧集，播客，第一集叫做加布的播客。
You know, they all have a title. So this is Gabe's podcast, written by Kelly Hannan and directed by Charlie Grandy. Here's how it starts. Gabe is going to approach Aaron at front reception, and he just says, hey, can you send a fax to Joe? And Aaron says, do you want the general fax line or her personal fax line? Joe has a personal fax line. She has two fax machines.
你知道的，它们都有名字。所以这是加布的播客，由凯利·哈南编剧，查理·格兰迪导演。故事是这样开始的。加布走向前台接待处的艾琳，他说，嘿，你能给乔发份传真吗？艾琳说，你要发到总传真线还是她的私人传真线？乔有私人传真线。她有两台传真机。
Hey, hey, we were supposed to get a fax with Clark Duke. Oh, that's right. And we have not gotten on that. Yeah. And we were going to fax each other. We're just reminding us. Yeah. Yeah, we're going to fax like bits.
嘿，嘿，我们本该收到一份有克拉克·杜克的传真。哦，对哦。我们还没弄那个。对。我们本来要互相发传真。我们只是提醒一下。对。对，我们要像发小段子一样发传真。
Exactly. Aaron goes on to ask Gabe if he's read Oscar's blog this morning. And you can really tell Gabe is super annoyed about Oscar having this blog. Yeah. Oscar announces he actually has just published another blog. It's not even 11 a.m. He's already put out another blog. I love the name of his blog. It's really great. Oscar's blog is called There's No Accounting for Taste. And Oscar explains it's anecdotes from his life as an accountant mixed with decorating tips. It's kind of the finer Things Club meets the accounting department. Yeah. And Joe loves it. Apparently, Joe Bennett is a huge fan. So much so that Oscar's blog is on the Sabre website. Gabe can't believe it. Gabe cannot believe it. I mean, this is a big deal. He has a talking head where he says, to make a name for yourself, you need to get something published on the Sabre website. The Sabre website is the mandatory homepage of every computer in the company. So every single computer in the company is seeing Oscar's blog. Yeah. But here's the thing. I think Gabe is mostly jealous that Oscar has Joe's gaze. Oh, yeah.
没错。艾琳接着问加布今天早上有没有看奥斯卡的博客。你真的能看出加布对奥斯卡有这个博客感到超级恼火。是的。奥斯卡宣布他其实刚刚又发表了一篇博客。现在还不到上午 11 点。他已经又发了一篇博客。我很喜欢他博客的名字。真的很棒。奥斯卡的博客叫“各有所好”（There's No Accounting for Taste）。奥斯卡解释说，这是他在会计生活中的趣闻轶事，还夹杂着装修技巧。这有点像是“精美事物俱乐部”与会计部的结合。是的。乔很喜欢。显然，乔·贝内特是超级粉丝。以至于奥斯卡的博客都登上了 Sabre 公司的网站。加布简直不敢相信。加布简直不敢相信。我的意思是，这可是件大事。他在剧中有一个独白镜头，他说，要在公司扬名立万，你需要把文章发表在 Sabre 网站上。Sabre 网站是公司每台电脑的强制主页。所以公司里的每一台电脑都能看到奥斯卡的博客。是的。但关键是，我觉得加布主要是嫉妒奥斯卡得到了乔的目光。哦，是的。
That Joe loves this. Yeah, that Joe has favoritism with him, that she wants to engage with him. Like, we learn as the webisode goes that Joe is constantly reaching out to Oscar and giving him notes on his blog. I'm like, Joe, what do you doing? You're running a whole company. What are you doing? You're not Oscar's editor. Hey, she loves, there's no accounting for taste. She does. She loves it. She loves it. And while Gabe is bummed, he wants to catch Joe's eye. So he's decided he's going to start a podcast. And he asks Kelly if she'll be on it.
乔很喜欢这个。是的，乔对他偏爱有加，她想与他互动。你看，随着网络剧的发展，我们了解到乔不断地联系奥斯卡，并就他的博客给他提出修改意见。我就想，乔，你在干什么？你经营着一整家公司呢。你在干什么？你又不是奥斯卡的编辑。嘿，她喜欢“各有所好”。她确实喜欢。她太喜欢了。虽然加布很沮丧，但他想吸引乔的注意。所以他决定开始做一个播客。他问凯利会不会上他的节目。
And she's like, no. You know what? This got me curious. Like nowadays, in 2025, I'm watching this webisode. And the idea of a podcast just is so part of our culture. But this was 2011. And I was like, were podcasts big in 2011? Like blogs were big.
而她的反应是，才不。你知道吗？这勾起了我的好奇心。就像现在，在 2025 年，我在看这部网络剧。播客的概念已经如此融入我们的文化。但这可是 2011 年。我就在想，2011 年播客很火吗？就像博客当时很火一样。
That was a big deal. Everybody, there were mommy bloggers and that whole thing was taking off. And just we had like our MySpace page blogs. I did a blog for TVguide.com. Like, blogging was it. But what about podcasting? So guess what I did? Did you find out what podcast?
那可是一件大事。每个人，当时有妈妈博主，那一整股潮流正在兴起。还有我们自己的 MySpace 博客页面。我曾为 TVguide.com 写过博客。那时候博客就是一切。但播客呢？所以你猜我做了什么？你查到了什么播客……
were happening in 2011? I did a little deep dive on the history of podcasting. The history? Not just what was happening when this episode came on, but the history of podcasting. I can't wait. I had to go to the beginning. And here's what I found out. You always do.
在 2011 年出现过吗？我对播客的历史做了一点深入研究。历史？不仅是这一集播出时的情况，还有播客的历史。我等不及了。我不得不从头说起。以下是我查到的结果。你总是这样。
You need the beginning. You need the origin story, lady. Well, the podcast feed was created by Dave Weiner and the first podcast. was radio source by Christopher Leiden. It was released in 2003. And it's still around. It's history's longest running podcast. Oh.
你需要从头说起。你需要起源故事，女士。好吧，播客种子（feed）是由戴夫·温纳（Dave Weiner）创建的，第一个播客是克里斯托弗·莱登（Christopher Leiden）的《无线电之源》（radio source）。它于 2003 年发布。现在它还在。这是历史上运行时间最长的播客。哦。
But the term podcast was not coined until 2004. This writer Ben Hammersley wrote an article in The Guardian, and he used the word podcast. but he only used it one time in the article. I found the article. And here is what Ben said. Quote, MP3 players, like Apple's iPod in many pockets,
但“播客”（podcast）这个词直到 2004 年才被创造出来。作家本·哈默斯利（Ben Hammersley）在《卫报》上写了一篇文章，他使用了“podcast”这个词。但他在文章中只用了一次。我找到了那篇文章。以下是本说的话。引述：“口袋里揣着像苹果 iPod 那样的 MP3 播放器，
audio production software cheap or free, and web blogging and established part of the internet. All the ingredients are there for a new boom in amateur radio. But what to call it? Audio blogging, podcasting, media? That's it. He was like wondering, what should we call this boom in like people having their own little radio stations? Yeah, he was spitballing. He was like, here's a few ideas I have.
廉价或免费的音频制作软件，以及作为互联网既定部分的网络博客。所有这些元素都具备了，业余无线电将迎来新一轮的繁荣。但该叫它什么呢？音频博客、播客、媒体？”就是这样。他当时在想，对于这种人们拥有自己的小型无线电台的热潮，我们该叫它什么？是的，他当时在即兴发挥。他就像是说，我有这几个想法。
Well, the word podcasting took off. In fact, in 2005, podcast was the word of the year by New Oxford American Dictionary. Hey. Also in 2005, Apple introduced podcasting to iTunes. but it wasn't until 2014 that podcasts really started to become popular. And that is credited to the popularity of the True Crime Podcasts serial, which by the way is the first podcast I ever listened to. Yeah, me too. Sam, you have been working in podcasting for a very long time. When did you start working at Earwool?
嗯，“播客”（podcasting）这个词流行起来了。事实上，在 2005 年，“podcast”被《新牛津美式词典》评为年度词汇。嘿。同样在 2005 年，苹果将播客引入了 iTunes。但直到 2014 年，播客才真正开始变得流行起来。这要归功于真实犯罪播客《Serial》的流行，顺便说一句，这也是我听过的第一个播客。对，我也是。萨姆，你从事播客工作已经很长时间了。你是什么时候开始在 Earwool 工作的？
probably 13 years ago, 12 years ago maybe. So what year was that? 2010 or 2011 maybe? So right around the time that Gabe was starting his podcast, you were working in podcasting. Exactly, yeah. Well, in 2011, when this episode was released, Adam Carolla set the Guinness World record for the most downloaded podcast of 2011. He was the podcast king of 2011.
大概 13 年前，也许 12 年前。那是什么年份？也许是 2010 年或 2011 年？所以就在加布开始做播客的时候，你就在从事播客工作了。没错，是的。嗯，在 2011 年这一集播出时，亚当·卡罗拉（Adam Carolla）创下了 2011 年下载量最多播客的吉尼斯世界纪录。他是 2011 年的播客之王。
Guinness Book of World Records. Wow. Yeah. But in general, podcasting did not really explode into like pop culture until 2014. Apparently, podcast listenership tripled between 2014 and 2019. Crazy. That is crazy. And we didn't even come on the scene until 2019.
吉尼斯世界纪录。哇。是的。但总的来说，播客直到 2014 年才真正爆发进入流行文化。显然，在 2014 年到 2019 年之间，播客的听众人数增加了两倍。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。而我们直到 2019 年才进入这个行业。
Exactly. Well, a lot has changed in podcasting even just in the six years that we've been doing it, and it's grown even so much since we started. Absolutely. I also have noticed that so many television shows now have their own podcast, you know? So sort of the way we did DVD commentaries and that was just part of our job. once we got the job on the show as an actor that it was just part of the package you signed up to do. And it seems like there's a lot of shows now that have these sort of after the episode podcast recaps.
没错。嗯，仅仅在我们做播客的这六年里，播客行业就发生了很大变化，自从我们开始以来，它的发展更是无比巨大。绝对的。我也注意到现在有那么多的电视剧都有自己的播客，你知道吗？就像我们当年做 DVD 评论音轨一样，那是我们工作的一部分。一旦你在剧中得到了演员的工作，这就成了你签约要做的一部分。现在似乎有很多节目都在剧集播完后推出这种回顾播客。
Yes. Yes, it's true. Well, back to this web episode, Kelly, like we said, is not going to do Gabe's podcast. And she has a talking head where she explains that she can't be the subject of Gabe's podcast because she's a rising pop stuff. and she's really concerned about over exposure. Yeah, she doesn't want to just, you know, wear people out with all of her fame. She's getting really famous. She really is. She's already done three blogs.
是的。是的，确实如此。好吧，回到这个网络剧集，凯利，正如我们所说，不会上加布的播客。她在独白中解释说，她不能成为加布播客的主题，因为她是个崭露头角的流行巨星，她非常担心过度曝光。是的，她不想仅仅，你知道的，用她所有的名气让大家感到厌烦。她变得越来越红了。确实如此。她已经做过三个博客了。
She says she's done Oscars blog, the subtle sexuality blog, and Aaron's subtle sexuality fan blog. I mean, just so many blogs. So many blogs. Well, Gabe is now going to hit up Creed, and Creed seems really surprised that Saber has a website. I do love what Creed says to Gede. Gabe, I love your podcast. And he's like, there isn't one yet. I haven't done it yet. It just kind of cracks me up. And then Gabe tells, and then Gabe tells Creed about Oscar's blog and he's super curious. He wants to check it out. He goes onto his computer and on Creed's screen is his own
她说她做过奥斯卡的博客、微妙性吸引力（subtle sexuality）博客以及艾琳的微妙性吸引力粉丝博客。我的意思是，有太多的博客了。太多的博客了。好吧，加布现在要去找克里德了，克里德似乎对 Sabre 公司有网站感到非常惊讶。我很喜欢克里德对加布说的话。加布，我很喜欢你的播客。而加布却说，现在还没有呢。我还没做呢。这真的让我笑出声来。然后加布告诉克里德关于奥斯卡的博客，克里德超级好奇。他想去瞧瞧。他打开电脑，而克里德屏幕上显示的是他自己的……
website. This tickled me so much. So, you know, we've already known that Creed had a blog called Creed Thoughts, right? And that's been around since about two thousand and seven at this time. Ryan mentioned it in The Job, but now we learn that Creed has a website. It's called Creed's WNBA Appreciation website. It has stats, teams, players, news archives, and the opening page is an article titled WNBA draft advice. Cassie, would you be following Creed's WNBA appreciation site? Absolutely. I mean, Cassie. That is so awesome, actually. It is. And Cassie, he has archives. This means he's been doing this a while. I hope he's still doing it. I know. Creed has a talking head now where he says, look, I love basketball and women. How does no one else get this? This is like the no-brainer to Creed. He's ahead of the trend. Yes. Yeah. Well, Gabe is still searching for someone to be on his podcast, so he approaches Meredith. Meredith is showing Creed that she can write with her feet. Gabe is going to say.
网站。这太让我开心了。所以，你知道的，我们早就知道克里德有一个叫“克里德的想法”（Creed Thoughts）的博客，对吧？这个博客从 2007 年左右就有了。瑞安在《工作》（The Job）一集中提到过它，但现在我们得知克里德有一个网站。它叫“克里德的 WNBA 欣赏网站”。上面有数据、球队、球员、新闻档案，首页是一篇题为《WNBA 选秀建议》的文章。卡茜，你会关注克里德的 WNBA 欣赏网站吗？绝对会。我是说，卡茜。这其实太棒了。确实如此。而且卡茜，他有档案。这意味着他做这个有一段时间了。我希望他现在还在做。我知道。克里德现在有一个独白镜头，他说，听着，我喜欢篮球和女人。怎么会没人懂这个？对克里德来说，这简直是显而易见的。他走在了潮流的前面。对的。是的。好吧，加布仍在寻找适合上他播客的人，于是他找到了梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思正在向克里德展示她可以用脚写字。加布要说的是……
skip Meredith. He's like, okay, she's doing her writing with her feet. I'm going to move on to Kevin. And Kevin is so excited. He spits out his bagel. He cannot wait to be on Gabe's podcast. Yeah, he has a talking head where he says, you know, it's such a good match for him. He's Irish. So he is a natural sayer of stories and yarn. Yeah. And that ends this first web episode. Well, we're moving on to the next part of the podcast webisode. It's called The First Entry. It was written by Mary Wall and directed by Charlie Grandy. Yeah, Gabe is sitting next to Kevin. He's got a little recorder. Kevin is just stapling some papers. And Gabe is kind of narrating. He's wondering, like, what happens when we stop for a moment and ask, why do we do activities like this? Why do we staple?
跳过梅雷迪思。他的反应是，好吧，她在用脚写字。我要去找凯文了。凯文兴奋极了。他把百吉饼都喷出来了。他迫不及待地想上加布的播客。是的，他有一个独白镜头，他说，你知道，这对他来说太般配了。他是爱尔兰人。所以他天生就会讲故事和编段子。是的。这就结束了第一集网络剧。好吧，我们进入播客网络剧的下一部分。它叫《第一条》（The First Entry）。由玛丽·沃尔（Mary Wall）编剧，查理·格兰迪（Charlie Grandy）导演。是的，加布坐在凯文旁边。他拿着一个小型录音机。凯文正在订一些文件。加布在一旁旁白。他在想，当我们停下一会儿，问问自己为什么要进行这样的活动时，会发生什么？我们为什么要订文件？
Yeah. Kevin answers and says, these things need to be stuck to those things, at which Angela interjects and says, who is going to listen to this nonsense? Gabe turns to her. He says, Angela, a rare instance of brains and beauty, a fairy tale princess stuck in a tower of paperwork, stoically spinning receipts into gold for the rumple steel skin we call the man. Angela's charmed. She's so delighted. She's smugly. She's smugly. So this scene is the first time we get to hear Gabe's podcasting voice. Did you notice he's kind of whisper talking? Yes. He's like stapling, stapling, stapling. Yes, and he's getting the sound of the stapler.
是的。凯文回答说，这些东西需要粘在那些东西上，这时安吉拉插话道：“谁会听这些废话？”加布转向她。他说：“安吉拉，兼具智慧与美貌的罕见典范，被困在高塔纸堆中的童话公主，把收据冷酷地纺成黄金，献给那个我们称之为‘男人’的侏儒妖（rumple steel skin）。”安吉拉被迷住了。她太高兴了。她沾沾自喜。她洋洋得意。所以这个场景是我们第一次听到加布的播客声音。你注意到了吗，他有点像是在耳语说话？是的。他就像在“订文件，订文件，订文件”。是的，他录下了订书机的声音。
It's very ASMR. It really is. It is. And lady, I told you, I found the most amazing podcast. It's called the Office ASMR. Oh, yes. Yes, yes, you did. Here's how it's described.
非常有 ASMR 的感觉。确实如此。是的，女士，我告诉你，我找到了最棒的播客。它叫《办公室 ASMR》（The Office ASMR）。哦，是的。是的，是的，你找到了。它是这样描述的：
The Office is a great show to fall asleep to. This is a podcast narrating each episode in a calm, relaxed way to help people fall asleep without screens. Amazing. Amazing. So like this guy, he describes the episodes in a soothing voice and you can just lay there and kind of imagine them. Yes. As you fall asleep is what it is. Exactly.
《办公室》是一部非常适合伴着入睡的好剧。这是一个以平静、放松的方式叙述每一集的播客，旨在帮助人们在没有屏幕的情况下入睡。太棒了。太棒了。所以这个人用舒缓的声音描述剧集，你可以躺在那里想象它们。是的。正如它所说，在你入睡的时候。完全正确。
It gets 4.6 out of five stars. and I thought we could hear a little bit. Let's hear it. Kevin's very excited that pregnant Pam and Kevin are eating a lot together. Second breakfast. Lunch, second lunch, first dinner. As they eat some kind of mac and cheese in the kitchen. One last ultra feast, says Kevin.
它的评分是 4.6 星（满分 5 星），我想我们可以听一听。我们来听听看。凯文非常兴奋，因为怀孕的潘和凯文经常一起吃东西。第二早餐。午餐，第二午餐，第一晚餐。当他们在厨房里吃某种通心粉和奶酪时。最后一场饕餮盛宴，凯文说。
Well, I have to say his voice is very soothing. He's doing a very good sleepy time voice. Yeah. And you know, if you're a huge fan of the show, your mind is filling in the picture. Yes, so you can just listen and fall asleep. Well, this podcast goes up until season six, episode 21, happy hour. And then there aren't anymore. I don't know if he stopped doing them or if he's coming back to finish,
嗯，我得说他的声音非常舒缓。他正在用一种非常适合睡觉的声音。是的。而且你知道的，如果你是这部剧的超级粉丝，你的脑海中就会浮现出画面。是的，所以你只需听着就能入睡。嗯，这个播客一直播到第六季第二十一集《欢乐时光》（Happy Hour）。然后就没有了。我不知道他是停止制作了还是会回来完成它，
but there are six seasons of the Office ASMR podcast for you. If you need a soothing The Office Descript. to fall asleep to. Well, now, Kelly and Aaron are going to march into the bullpen. They're going to go over to accounting. Kelly is furious because Oscar posted a picture of her eating a chili dog in his blog. Well, here's the thing that cracked me up. She's not mad that she's eating a chili dog. That's not her issue. It's the fact that he did not crop out the other people in the picture. She wanted it just to be her. Yeah, she gave him permission to use the photo, but she was on the condition that he crop everyone else out. And he says, I'm sorry, I didn't have time.
不过，这里有六季《办公室》ASMR播客供你选择。如果你需要一段舒缓的《办公室》Descript录音来帮助入睡。那么现在，凯利和亚伦要走进办公区了。他们要走向会计部。凯利非常生气，因为奥斯卡在他的博客里发了一张她吃辣椒热狗的照片。事情是这样的，这一点让我笑喷了。她生气的不是自己在吃辣椒热狗。这不是她的问题。问题在于他没有把照片里的其他人给裁剪掉。她希望画面里只有她自己。是的，她授权他使用这张照片，但前提是他要把其他人全部裁剪掉。而他说，对不起，我没时间。
She's like, forget it. We're never going to be in your blog again. Gabe will do your podcast. Angela pipes in and says she would also be interested in doing the podcast. His flattery worked. I mean, he's called her a fairy tale princess. Come on. Yeah, she's in.
她的反应是，算了。我们再也不会出现在你的博客里了。加布会去录你的播客。安吉拉插话道，她也有兴趣参加这个播客。他的奉承起作用了。我的意思是，他叫她童话公主。拜托。是的，她加入了。
Now we're in the conference room. It's Kelly, Aaron, Kevin Creed, Angela, and Meredith. and the white board behind them says, quote, having it all. Yes, this is the subject of Gabe's podcast. This is what he wants everybody to kind of think about. What does having it all mean to them? Yeah, and you know, I guess they're staying after hours to have this conference room meeting. And Lady Creed has my favorite talking head of the entire the podcast episode series right here.
现在我们在会议室里。有凯利、亚伦、凯文、克里德、安吉拉和梅雷迪思。他们身后的白板上写着，引述一下，“拥有一切”。是的，这就是加布播客的主题。这就是他想让大家思考的问题。对他们来说，“拥有一切”意味着什么？是的，你知道的，我猜他们是留下来加班开这个会议室会议的。而克里德女士贡献了整整一期播客系列中最让我喜欢的单人访谈镜头。
About the Tupperware? Yeah, I think we should hear it. Okay. Tell the truth, I'm not too excited about staying tonight, but my sister is having a Tupperware party. If I was there, I would just buy everything up. He'd buy it all up. Buy all the Tupperware. Also, Crete has a sister.
关于特百惠（Tupperware）的那个？是的，我觉得我们应该听一下。好的。说实话，我对今晚留下来不是很兴奋，但我的姐姐要办一个特百惠派对。如果我在那儿，我就会把所有东西都买光。他会全部买光。把所有特百惠都买下来。还有，克里德居然有个姐姐。
Oh, yeah. He sells Tupperware. That would be me. I would buy it all up. I could not go to a Tupperware party and not leave without a whole set. My Tupperware cabinet is a hot mess again. I know. Ours is too.
哦，对。他卖特百惠。那肯定就是我了。我会全部买光。我不可能去参加一个特百惠派对却不带走一整套。我的特百惠橱柜又是一团糟了。我知道。我们的也是。
So is my sock drawer. Again, both of those areas, I clean them. constantly, I'm always like, where do the socks go? I don't know. Why are these two areas of the home? Why do they undo themselves so consistently? I don't know. I have a basket of socks without their partner that I just, I won't give up because every
我的袜子抽屉也是。同样的，这两个地方，我一直在清理它们，我总是在想，袜子都去哪儿了？我不知道。为什么家里的这两个地方？为什么它们总是这么快就乱成一团？我不知道。我有一个装单只袜子的篮子，我就是舍不得扔，因为每
once in a while I find the other one. So what is that? I don't know. I don't know where they go. And also, I don't know how to store Tupperware. Do you stack it without the lids one inside the other and then put the lids on the other side or do you have the lids on top of the container and you don't separate the lids and the containers like how do people do it because mine's always a mess and I'm looking
过一段时间我就会找到另一只。所以那是什么？我不知道。我不知道它们去哪儿了。而且，我不知道怎么收纳特百惠。你是把它们不盖盖子一个套一个地叠起来，然后把盖子放在另一边，还是把盖子盖在盒子上，不把盖子和盒子分开——大家到底是怎么做的，因为我的总是乱七八糟，而且我在找
for the right lid and I can't find it well I prefer to pair them I like to put the lid on the container and then store it together like they are best friends and they want to be stored together they don't want to be separated okay but I'm the only person in my family who does it so if anyone else unloads the dishwasher, they just willy-nilly throw it in the cabinet. I can't get everyone on board with my system. And I mean, I think I just answered my question why my Tupperware cabinet is always in disarray. It's because I'm the only person attending to it. You have multiple systems. But what's with the socks? The socks, no one's like, I mean, I don't know. I'm just saying like, also the junk drawer. Why? Why does, why do I organize these spaces and then they disorganize themselves?
合适的盖子却找不到。嗯，我更喜欢把它们配成对，我喜欢把盖子盖在盒子上，然后把它们收纳在一起，就像它们是好朋友一样，它们想被收纳在一起，它们不想分开。好吧，但我是家里唯一这么做的人，所以如果其他人卸洗碗机，他们就会随心所欲地把它们扔进橱柜里。我没法让所有人都支持我的系统。我的意思是，我想我刚刚回答了我为什么我的特百惠橱柜总是乱七八糟的问题。因为我是唯一一个维护它的人。你有好几套系统。但是袜子是怎么回事？袜子，没有人会——我的意思是，我不知道。我只是想说，还有杂物抽屉。为什么？为什么——为什么我整理了这些空间，然后它们又自己变乱了？
When I organized my makeup drawer like three years ago and it's still great. It's terrific. Well, it's because you're the only one using it. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. You're right. Every place in our house that's what I call sort of like a community space is always the most cluttered space. Yeah, because there's multiple systems at play, not one person's system.
当我大约三年前整理我的化妆抽屉时，它现在还是很棒。太棒了。嗯，那是因为你是唯一一个使用它的人。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。你说得对。我们家里每一个我称之为某种社区空间的地方，总是最杂乱的空间。是的，因为有多个系统在起作用，而不是某一个人的系统。
Yeah. Okay. Where were we? I don't know. Well, Gabe is now going to ask everyone. one, what does it mean having it all? What does that mean to you? And Kelly says, well, it's a job and a family. Aaron says the same thing. They kind of like give each other a little squeeze. Like, oh, we're, we said the same thing. And then Angela says the same thing. Yeah. And then Meredith says, I have a job in a family and it ate shit.
好吧。我们刚才说到哪了？我不知道。好吧，盖布现在要问每个人，“拥有一切”意味着什么？这对你意味着什么？凯莉说，嗯，是一份工作和一个家庭。亚伦也说了同样的话。他们有点像互相捏了一下。就像，噢，我们——我们说的是同一句话。然后安吉拉也说了同样的话。是的。然后梅雷迪思说，我有一份工作和一个家庭，而且它糟糕透顶。
And then she goes, wait, wait, shouldn't I be saying this to your cameras? Where are your cameras? And Gabe, lady, he says something that speaks deep to you and I's heart and soul. He taps his little recorder and he goes, it's an audio podcast. Yes. We laugh about this all the time. We actually got a fan question lady from Maddie F in Daytona Beach who said, For Office Lady 6.0, can we incorporate video? What do you think?
然后她说，等等，等等，我不是应该对你们的摄像机说这些吗？你们的摄像机在哪里？盖布，天哪，他说的话深深触动了你和我的心和灵魂。他拍了拍他的小录音机，然后他说，这是一个音频播客。是的。我们经常拿这个开玩笑。我们实际上收到了一位来自代托纳比奇的粉丝Maddie F的提问，女士，她说，对于《办公室女士》6.0，我们可以加入视频吗？你觉得呢？
I would love to see a video version of the podcast while I'm at lunch and pretend I'm at lunch with you both. I bet we can convince Sam to hook this up. Oh my gosh, Sam, this is your job now. Maddie went on to say, I'm glad the podcast is continuing since I've been re-listening from the beginning again anyway. Cheers. Well, Maddie, we have discussed many times the idea of adding a video element of the podcast, and it boils down to this. I don't want to. Yeah, I mean, it's a podcast. Aren't podcasts just by definition something you listen to? Why do we have to watch everything? Why does everything have a video? Like, I like the idea of something that I just listened to. And I think once a camera's there, it changes how you share. It's not as intimate. I feel like I would be aware of the camera. In some way, the camera would be like this extra person in the room that I would.
我很想在吃午饭时看这个播客的视频版，假装我和你们俩一起吃午饭。我敢打赌我们可以说服山姆搞定这个。噢天哪，山姆，这就是你现在的工作了。玛蒂接着说，我很高兴播客能继续下去，因为反正我一直在从头重新听。干杯。好吧，玛蒂，我们已经多次讨论过在播客中加入视频元素的想法，归根结底就是这样。我不想。是的，我的意思是，这是一个播客。从定义上讲，播客不就是用来听的东西吗？为什么我们非得看所有东西？为什么所有东西都有视频？就像，我喜欢那种只需要听的东西的想法。而且我认为一旦有了摄像机，它就会改变你的分享方式。它就不那么亲密了。我觉得我会意识到摄像机的存在。某种程度上，摄像机就像是房间里的这个额外的人，我会。
I would clock in to the camera. I just like that there's not this third thing in the room. It's just me and you having a conversation. Well, listen, we tried it very early on back in the Earwolf Studios. Josh and Lee came in with two cameras and they set up lights for us. And we tried to record the podcast while we were being videotaped. And it was horrible. We didn't even put that podcast out.
我会对摄像机产生防备。我只是喜欢房间里没有这第三样东西。只有我和你在对话。好吧，听着，我们在早期的埃尔沃尔夫工作室里非常早的时候就尝试过。乔许和李带着两台摄像机进来，为我们设置了灯光。我们试图在被录像的同时录制播客。太糟糕了。我们甚至没有把那个播客发布出去。
We stopped in the middle and we were like, shut off the camera. cameras. I was so self-conscious. I was so like, I don't know. I didn't like it. Also, sometimes I don't want to brush my hair before we record. And I want to wear my sweatpants. And I want to be in my cozies. And I just don't want to feel like I'm on display. Oh, I know. Because then there's always snarky people that are like, oh, is that what her chin looks like now? Yeah, exactly. Exactly. I don't need the snark comments and I just, I don't know. Maddie, you're so sweet. Maddie just wants to have lunch with us. I know, Maddie. I just loved what you said. And thank you so much for re-listing from the beginning and I just so appreciate you. But yeah, I mean, our husbands really did try. They came in. And Jenna, it's so funny to me when you just said, we were like, shut the cameras off because there were two different reactions in the room. One, you got. kind of in your head, like, with the cameras there, right?
我们在中间停下来，我们说，关掉摄像机。摄像机。我太自我意识过剩了。我太像——我不知道。我不喜欢它。还有，有时候我们在录音前不想梳头。我想穿我的运动裤。我想穿得舒舒服服的。我只是不想觉得自己像是在被展出。噢，我知道。因为那样总会有尖酸刻薄的人说，噢，这就是她现在的下巴长相吗？是的，没错。没错。我不需要那些刻薄的评论，我只是——我不知道。玛蒂，你太甜了。玛蒂只是想和我们一起吃午饭。我知道，玛蒂。我太喜欢你刚才说的话了。非常感谢你从头开始重听，我真的很感激你。但是，是的，我的意思是，我们的丈夫们确实尝试过。他们进来了。珍娜，当你说出那句“我们就像是，把摄像机关掉”时，我觉得太搞笑了，因为房间里有两种不同的反应。第一，你变得。
Yeah. And it kind of shut you down. It did. I began to perform to the cameras, like an idiot. I'd be like, well, then that's what she said, but I eat it to do. I was like, oh, God, what's happening? But Maddie, thank you. We would have lunch with you, Maddie.
有点陷入自己的思绪，就像，摄像机在那里一样，对吧？
So. We would. I'd love to have lunch with you. Yeah. Well, in the end of this web episode, Gabe is going to cave. He is going to do a video. podcast, a la Meet the Press, which is really, spoiler alert, going to be kind of just a talk show. Yes.
是的。而且这有点让你说不出话来。确实如此。我开始像个白痴一样对着摄像机表演。我会说，嗯，那是她说的，但我吃定它了。我当时想，噢，天哪，发生什么事了？但是玛蒂，谢谢你。我们会和你一起吃午饭的，玛蒂。
I mean, but look, Meredith has all the equipment, you guys. She has video equipment, lights, release forms. In her van. In her van. And Gabe sees his moment to, you know, have his sort of irreverent 80s punk scene. What? What is this 80s punk scene that he thinks he is? I don't know.
所以。我们会去的。我很想和你一起吃午饭。是的。嗯，在这个网络剧集的结尾，盖布要妥协了。他要做一个视频。播客，模仿《会见新闻界》（Meet the Press），而这实际上，剧透警告，将只是一种脱口秀。是的。
It's going to be classy, refined, and edgy. So buckle in. Well, this brings us to the final installment of the podcast webisodes titled The Debut. It was written by Jonathan Hughes and directed by Charlie Grandy. And sure enough, everyone's in the conference room. And they've set it up kind of like a talk show space with a couch and Absolutely. The camera.
我的意思是，但是看，梅雷迪思拥有所有的设备，伙计们。她有视频设备、灯光、授权书。在她的面包车里。在她的面包车里。盖布看到了他的时刻，你知道的，展现他那种不羁的80年代朋克风格。什么？他以为自己是什么80年代朋克风格？我不知道。
Yeah, there's like a little sofa and a table with a table with a couch. plant and two coffee mugs and then Gabe's in the chair like the host. Off to the side, Creed's going to be playing music. He's the band. Yeah. Kevin is there. He's worn his toupee. I was wondering, is anyone tracking the toupee? How many times is the toupee in the series? I know it's in Training Day. He wants to impress DeAngelo. Yeah. I think he wore it to Pam's wedding. Yes. Did he wear it to Shrewt Farms? Halloween. I don't think he wore it to Shrewt arms. I don't think he wore it to Angela's wedding, no. No, but yeah.
这将是优雅、精致而前卫的。所以系好安全带。好吧，这就把我们带到了题为《首秀》（The Debut）的播客网络剧集的最后一部分。它由乔纳森·休斯（Jonathan Hughes）编剧，查理·格兰迪（Charlie Grandy）导演。果不其然，每个人都在会议室里。他们把它布置得像一个脱口秀空间，有沙发和绝对的。摄像机。
These are good questions. I'd be curious for someone who's tracking how many times we see this wig. Kevin's going to offer to be Gabe's sidekick. Gabe was not planning to have a sidekick, but so be it, Kevin is now the sidekick. Even though he keeps messing up all of the introductions. He's not a great sidekick so far. Yeah, no, he's not a very good sidekick. Well, Gabe is going to welcome his first guest, and it is Kelly Kapoor.
是的，就像有一张小沙发和一张桌子，桌子上有植物和两个咖啡马克杯，然后盖布坐在椅子上像个主持人。在一旁，克里德将要弹奏音乐。他是乐队。是的。凯文也在那里。他戴着他的假发。我在想，有人在追踪那顶假发吗？这顶假发在剧集中出现过多少次？我知道它在《训练日》（Training Day）里出现过。他想给德安杰洛留下深刻印象。是的。我想他去帕姆的婚礼时戴了。是的。他在去舒鲁特农场时戴了吗？万圣节。我想他没去舒鲁特农场戴。我想他没去安吉拉的婚礼戴，没有。没有，但是是的。
Yes. So here's the deal, you guys. Ryan is going to give Kelly the tips that you need to be a great talk show host. Ready? Here they are. Wave as you enter. Flirt with the host. Tell a mildly amusing story. Act surprised when you're asked to share about your project you're there to promote. And push up bra, question mark. So let's see how the Dundermifflin employees do as a talk show guest. Her Ryan's tips. Are you ready? Okay. Here is Kelly's interview. I was going out to dinner the other night. Went to this Mongolian barbecue place. Basically, they just give you a bunch of raw food. You put it in a bowl and then they cook it up for you.
这些都是好问题。我很想知道追踪我们看到这个假发多少次的人会怎么说。凯文将主动提出担任盖布的副手。盖布原本没打算找副手，但事已至此，凯文现在就是副手了。尽管他一直在把所有的介绍都搞砸。到目前为止，他不是一个出色的副手。是的，不，他不是一个很好的副手。好吧，盖布要欢迎他的第一位嘉宾，那就是凯莉·卡普尔。
But I didn't know this. My boyfriend didn't tell me. So I'm just sitting there eating a raw bean sprout being like, they should call this place Mongolian salad bar. Crazyest stuff happens to me. I love that she's like the craziest stuff happens to me. All right. She waved. She was a little flirty. She told a mildly amusing story. What do we think? Did she check off all the things?
是的。所以情况是这样的，伙计们。瑞恩将给凯莉提供成为一名优秀脱口秀主持人所需的秘诀。准备好了吗？它们来了。进场时挥手。调戏主持人。讲一个温和有趣的笑话。当被问及你要宣传的项目时，表现得十分惊讶。还有推胸罩，问号。所以让我们看看邓德米夫林的员工作为脱口秀嘉宾表现如何。她的瑞恩的秘诀。你准备好了吗？好的。这是凯莉的采访。我前几天晚上出去吃晚饭。去了那家蒙古烤肉店。基本上，他们只给你一堆生食。你把它放进碗里，然后他们为你烹制。
I think she did pretty well. We didn't get to her talking about her project that she's there to promote, but so far, yes. Next up is Meredith, and she just plays the cowbell with her feet. Creed is really into it. He's tapping his foot along with her. And now we have Creed's interview. Let's hear it. The problem, Gabe, with a question of having it all, is that it deals with externals. What have I done? What do I own? None of this matters. What matters is what's happening internally if you're happy from within. That is an amazing answer. Look at me. I'm the most content person I know. And I live in a tent with a woman made of old soup cans. How do you do? Okay, so I'm supposed to rate that. Well, I think. he didn't tick any of the boxes. Well, I do think he had an interesting share, but then it went south.
但我不知道这一点。我男朋友没有告诉我。所以我只是坐在那里吃着生豆芽，心想，他们应该把这个地方叫做蒙古沙拉吧。最疯狂的事情发生在我身上。我喜欢她那种“最疯狂的事情发生在我身上”的语气。好吧。她挥手了。她有点调情。她讲了一个温和有趣的笑话。我们觉得怎么样？她把所有的项目都勾选了吗？
Yeah. Yeah. But so far on Ryan's list, Creed's interview did not go great. No. I mean, Meredith's didn't either. True. And so here's the thing. I was thinking about this, and Jenna, you and I have done a ton of talk shows together. I mean, we've done them separately on our own, but then we also did a whole bunch together. And I wondered how many things we checked off of Ryan's list. Oh, okay. I looked at a bunch of our interviews, and I picked one from when we did Seth Myers, because that's one of my favorites. Oh, same. Yeah.
我觉得她做得挺好的。我们还没谈到她要去宣传的项目，但到目前为止，是的。接下来是梅雷迪思，她正用脚敲着牛铃。克里德真的很投入。他跟着她的节奏用脚打拍子。现在是克里德的采访。我们听听看。盖布，关于“拥有一切”这个问题的麻烦在于，它处理的是外在的东西。我做了什么？我拥有什么？这些都不重要。重要的是内在发生了什么，如果你内心感到快乐。这真是一个惊人的回答。看着我。我是我认识的最心满意足的人。我住在一个用旧汤罐头做成的女性的帐篷里。你好吗？好吧，所以我要给那个打分。嗯，我觉得。他没有勾选任何选项。嗯，我确实认为他分享了一个有趣的内容，但后来方向就偏了。
So I wore a push-up bra. So I can tell you I've already hit one of the things on the list. There you go. You wore that great suit. I loved it. Yes, I borrowed that suit from Lindsay Price. She's my de facto stylist when I have to do things. You just go to her house.
是的。是的。但到目前为止在瑞恩的名单上，克里德的采访进行得不是很好。没有。我的意思是，梅雷迪思的也没有。确实。所以事情是这样的。我一直在想这个，珍娜，你和我一起做过大量的脱口秀。我的意思是，我们分别单干过，但后来我们也一起做了很多。我想知道我们在瑞恩的名单上勾选了多少项。噢，好吧。我看了我们的一堆采访，我挑选了我们在上塞斯·梅尔斯（Seth Myers）节目时的一个，因为那是我的最爱之一。噢，我也是。是的。
She goes into her own closet and brings me things. That's amazing. I love her. I love that. Well, okay, so check. Pushup bra. Check. In this interview when we walk out, we wave lady. So check. We did it. Mm-hmm. And we tell a bunch of different stories. And here's one we told to promote our book. So I think that checks another box. Oh, yes. And let's see if we tell a mildly amusing story, okay? Okay. Let's see. So you're going back, this podcast, as you guys recollecting your time together on the show, obviously you were both there the whole time. How often do your memories differ? Oh, my gosh. Well, when we started writing this book, there was one that came up right away, which was that when you got...
所以我戴了一个推胸罩。所以我可以告诉你，我已经命中了名单上的其中一项。这不就对了。你穿的那套西装真棒。我很喜欢。是的，那套西装我是从林赛·普莱斯（Lindsay Price）那里借来的。当我需要做事情时，她是我事实上的造型师。你直接去她家。
She got us backstage at the Emmys on the actual stage. Here's what happens. Okay, no, listen. Here's the thing. She was hungry. I don't like to be hungry. Yeah. Okay.
她走进自己的衣柜，给我拿东西。太棒了。我爱她。我喜欢那样。好吧，所以，打勾。推胸罩。打勾。在这个采访中，当我们走出去时，我们挥手了，女士。所以打勾。我们做到了。嗯-hmm。我们讲了一堆不同的故事。这里有一个我们为宣传我们的书而讲的故事。所以我认为这又勾选了一项。噢，是的。让我们看看我们是否讲了一个温和有趣的笑话，好吗？好的。让我们看看。所以你要回头看，这个播客，当你们回忆起在剧中共度的时光时，显然你们两个自始至终都在那里。你们的记忆有多大不同？噢，天哪。好吧，当我们开始写这本书时，有一个立刻浮现出来，那就是当你得到……
I'm not one of those actresses that doesn't eat food. I like to eat the food and I eat a lot of food and I was very hungry. Sure. And we couldn't find food anywhere. So I said, Angela, come on, we've got to get something to eat. So I found this nice lady and she had a headset and a clipboard. Yeah, she walked very fast and she kept going, shh, shh, sh. And she took us to this little like tent, like a dimly lit tent.
她把我们带到了艾美奖的后台，就在舞台上。事情是这样的。好吧，不，听着。事情是这样的。她饿了。我可不喜欢饿肚子。是的。好吧。
It was not a tent. It was a giant curtain on the Emmy stage. Like Emmy presenters and people were right there and she was like, But there was a whole, like, charcutory station. And there were these cookies. Yeah. Yeah. And so, but we didn't realize we were, I forgot this story when we were writing the book.
我可不是那种不吃东西的女演员。我喜欢吃东西，而且我吃很多东西，我当时非常饿。当然。而且我们到处都找不到吃的。所以我说，安吉拉，来吧，我们得找点吃的。所以我找到了这位漂亮的女士，她戴着耳机，拿着剪贴板。是的，她走得非常快，而且一直说，嘘，嘘，嘘。她把我们带到了这个像帐篷一样的小地方，像一个光线昏暗的帐篷。
Angela said, we have to tell about that time that Lawrence Fishburn was given a stink eye because you were eating the salami next to him. I mean, I vaguely heard him say something like, who the F or these folks? And then I said, Jenna, wrap it up. Shum the salami. Oh, wait. that's not bad. But you know what I mean. That's what she said.
那不是帐篷。那是艾美奖舞台上的一个巨大窗帘。就像艾美奖颁奖嘉宾和其他人就在那里，她就像是。但那里有一个完整的，类似于熟食拼盘的台子。还有这些饼干。是的。是的。所以，但是我们没有意识到我们正在，当我们写这本书时，我把这个故事忘了。
There we go. Oh, wow. That's so funny. I forgot we told that story. When we were writing the book, I forgot the story and then I forgot we told that on television. Well, you know what? We also talk about the dance that we made up where we file papers and we did the dance, lady. I remember that. Yeah. But Seth was great. I think we checked off some of the boxes. I think we did an excellent job. I'll have you know, I have run into Lawrence Fishburn since.
安吉拉说，我们得讲讲那次劳伦斯·菲什伯恩（Lawrence Fishburn）翻白眼的事，因为你在他旁边吃萨拉米香肠。我的意思是，我隐约听到他说了一些类似于“谁特么是这些家伙”之类的话。然后我说，珍娜，结束吧。吃萨拉米香肠。噢，等等。那还不错。但你知道我的意思。这就是她说的。
And he is an absolutely delightful gentleman. When you're not eating cheese right over his shoulder before he's going out on stage, he's probably a really nice guy. I didn't bring it up. I didn't bring it up. No, don't, don't. But he is a gem of a human. So, yes.
我们到了。噢，哇。太搞笑了。我忘了我们讲过那个故事。当我们写这本书时，我忘了这个故事，然后我忘了我们在电视上讲过这个。好吧，你知道吗？我们还谈到了我们编造的那个关于整理文件的舞蹈，我们跳了那个舞蹈，女士。我记得那个。是的。但塞斯太棒了。我想我们勾选了一些选项。我认为我们做得非常出色。我得告诉你，我后来又遇到过劳伦斯·菲什伯恩。
That's a full circle moment. It was a full circle. I mean, when I ended up in a conversation with him, I immediately thought, oh, my gosh. Yes. Does he know? Does he remember? He doesn't remember. I'm sure that I crashed the food table at the Emmys.
他绝对是一位令人愉快的绅士。当你不在他上台前正对着他的肩膀吃奶酪时，他可能真的是个很好的人。我没有提这件事。我没有提这件事。不，别，别。但他绝对是个宝藏般的人。所以，是的。
It's one of my favorite stories. Listen, I'll get you into some adventures when I'm hungry. No doubt about it. Well, after Creed's ending to his interview, talking about the lady made out of soup cans, Gabe is done. He's like, just forget it. Forget it. Yeah. All he wanted was a simple discussion about business and he got this freak show. That's what he says. Yeah. Everybody storms out. Yeah, they're ticked off. Yeah, this is not going to happen. Gabe is not going to have a podcast, he's thinking. But then Oscar comes in. Yeah. And Gabe's like, you'll do my podcast? He's clearly so happy that someone is going to do his podcast. And as he starts to interview Oscar, Meredith is like, nah-uh, not with my cameras, you don't. She grabs both of them. And as she leaves, the tripod catches the blinds and she drags half the blinds out.
这是一个圆满的时刻。这是一个圆满了。我的意思是，当我最终与他对话时，我立刻想，噢，天哪。是的。他知道吗？他还记得吗？他记不得了。我确信我大闹了艾美奖的美食桌。
That was not planned. That just happened. And I thought that was really funny. That was fun. So that's it for the podcast. It's not going to happen. No. We see a title card at the end that reads this.
这是我最喜欢的故事之一。听着，当我饿的时候，我会带你经历一些冒险。毫无疑问。好吧，在克里德采访的结尾，谈到那个由汤罐头制成的女性之后，盖布受够了。他就像是，算了吧。算了吧。是的。他想要的只是一场关于业务的简单讨论，而他得到的却是一场怪胎秀。他是这么说的。是的。每个人都气冲冲地走了。是的，他们生气了。是的，这不会发生了。盖布心想，他不会有什么播客了。但接着奥斯卡进来了。是的。盖布就像是，你要做我的播客？他显然很高兴有人要做他的播客。当他开始采访奥斯卡时，梅雷迪思就像是，想得美，用我的摄像机可不行。她抓住他们两个。当她离开时，三脚架勾住了百叶窗，她把半个百叶窗都拉了出来。
Gabe Lewis Productions, number one. Sadly, this will be my first and last podcast, as Oscar has decided he desperately needs me to help him with his blog. It was a tough call. But in the end, the blog offered the kind of proofreading experience one cannot pass up. Also, I'd like to think of myself as the type of guy who does the unexpected. I guess that's the punk in me, signed Gabe. Well, that's where the 80s punk comes in, lady. Yeah, I do love that.
那不是计划好的。那是刚刚发生的。我觉得那真的很有趣。那很有趣。所以播客就这样结束了。它不会发生了。没有。我们在最后看到了一张标题卡，上面写着这个。
It was the opportunity of proofreading that one could not pass up. Yeah. Because everyone loves to proofread. Well, there you have it, everybody. That is the web episode, the podcast. You can see it over on Peacock, and you can also see it on NBC's YouTube. Well, we're going to take a break. And when we come back, we are going to share with you guys our very first time trying to do a podcast.
盖布·刘易斯制作公司，第一号。可悲的是，这将是我的第一个也是最后一个播客，因为奥斯卡决定他迫切需要我帮他处理他的博客。这是一个艰难的决定。但最后，博客提供了那种不容错过的校对经验。此外，我愿意认为自己是那种会做意料之外事情的人。我想这就是我身上的朋克精神，盖布署名。好吧，这就是80年代朋克切入的地方，女士。是的，我很喜欢那个。
Hello, we are back. And in honor of Gabe starting his podcast. in this web episode, we thought this would be a fun time to share our pilot episode of Office Ladies. Yes. So you guys, I was going through my digital clutter recently and I found it. It was buried way back there. So here's the thing. At the time that we recorded this, we didn't even realize we were doing a pilot of anything. We didn't think we were podcasting or anything like that. We had been cleaning out our garages and kind of organizing all of our office memorabilia. And, Jenna, we were trading messages about it and we said, you know what, before we clean out all these bins, maybe we need to document some of this so we don't forget.
那是校对的机会，让人无法错过。是的。因为每个人都喜欢校对。好吧，你们都看到了。这就是网络剧集，《播客》。你可以在Peacock上观看，你也可以在NBC的YouTube上观看。好吧，我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将与大家分享我们第一次尝试制作播客的经历。
Even if it's something we could give our kids someday. Yeah, we kept calling each other and being like, oh my gosh, look at what I found. And then that made me think of this. But we were also like, you know, who knows, maybe one day we'll write a book. We need to get these stories down. So I went over to Angela's house and we just recorded ourselves on her iPhone. I had just found. a bunch of photos from our office Halloween episodes. So I said, Angie, I'm going to come talk about all my memories from doing Halloween episodes. And, you know, we did it. And when it was over, I don't think we really thought much of it because at the time, we were really more in, like, archive mode. Yeah, I didn't think anything of it. But I remember Josh was like, what did you guys do out there? And I said, well, we kind of recorded our memories of Halloween episodes. And I was like, here, do you want to hear it? And he listened to it and he was like, Angie, you know, I think this is a podcast. Which was so wild because at the time I was working on splitting up together and Oliver Hudson had literally like the week before said to me, Jenna, you should start a podcast. I think he would like podcasting because he knew that I liked being at home and sweatpants.
你好，我们回来了。为了纪念盖布在这个网络剧集中开始他的播客，我们觉得现在是一个分享我们《办公室女士》试播集的好时机。是的。所以伙计们，我最近在清理我的数字杂物时发现了它。它被深深地埋在后面。所以事情是这样的。在我们录制这个的时候，我们甚至没有意识到我们在做什么试播集。我们不认为我们在做播客或类似的事情。我们一直在清理我们的车库，并整理我们所有的办公室纪念品。而且，珍娜，我们为此交换了信息，我们说，你知道的，在我们清理所有这些箱子之前，也许我们需要记录其中的一些，这样我们就不会忘记。
So that was like now Josh was saying this could be a podcast and Oliver Hudson was like, Jenna, you should do a podcast. Yeah. So you and I were like, wait, is this something? And so Josh was like, guys, I'm going to edit it. I'm going to clean it up a little. I'm going to add some music to kind of move things along. And he did. And he said, what do you think? And we were like, oh my gosh, maybe this is something. Yeah. I mean, this is what we sent out to different companies when we started taking meetings for doing a podcast. This is what we gave them as an example of what our podcast might be. So we thought it might be. So we thought it might be. fun for you to hear how it all started. Yeah, here it is everyone, the office ladies pilot. Okay, this is March 7th. It is Jenna's birthday. She is 45 today. I am. We just went on a hike for her birthday. And now we are sitting in what was once my rundown garage that we were made into my office. Office slash guest room slash pool house slash kid game out. Game mom. And Jen and I are really excited. This is the first time we are going to read some of our pages out loud together. While Jenna reads, she's going first. I am eating a turkey wrap and chips and salsa, so I hope that's not annoying.
即使这是我们有一天可以留给孩子的东西。是的，我们不断地给对方打电话，说，噢，天哪，看看我找到了什么。然后这让我想起了这个。但我们也在想，谁知道呢，也许有一天我们会写一本书。我们需要把这些故事记下来。所以我去了安吉拉的家，我们只是用她的iPhone把自己录了下来。我刚刚找到。从我们的办公室万圣节剧集中找到的一堆照片。所以我说，安吉拉，我要来谈谈我制作万圣节剧集的所有回忆。而且，你知道，我们做到了。当它结束时，我认为我们并没有真正多想，因为当时我们确实更多地处于，类似于，档案模式。是的，我没多想。但我记得乔许说，你们在外面做什么？我说，嗯，我们算是录下了我们对万圣节剧集的回忆。我当时想，给你，你想听吗？他听了之后说，安吉拉，你知道，我觉得这是一个播客。这太疯狂了，因为当时我正在致力于《分居在一起》（Splitting Up Together），而奥利弗·哈德森（Oliver Hudson）在 literalmente 就在前一周对我说，珍娜，你应该开始做个播客。我觉得你会喜欢播客，因为他知道我喜欢呆在家里的运动裤里。
Well, I'm just really excited to listen to this later and transcribe it and hear your chip. I think that is going to be really fun for me. It keeps on giving Jenna. All right, so it was my job to dive deep into the Halloween episodes, not just the Halloween episodes, but just Halloween in general on the office, because it was a very special time. It was. We had a lot of fun. And I was thinking about why. Why was it such a very special, highly anticipated holiday on the set of the office?
所以就像现在乔许说这可能是一个播客，而奥利弗·哈德森则说，珍娜，你应该做一个播客。是的。所以你和我都在想，等等，这是个东西吗？所以乔许就说，伙计们，我要剪辑一下。我要稍微清理一下。我要加点音乐来推动事情的发展。他照做了。他说，你们觉得怎么样？我们当时想，噢，天哪，也许这真的是个东西。是的。我的意思是，这就是我们开始参加播客会议时发送给不同公司的东西。这就是我们给他们的例子，说明我们的播客可能是什么样的。所以我们认为它可能是。所以我们认为它可能是。你们听听这一切是怎么开始的，会很有趣。是的，给大家听听，办公室女士试播集。好的，这是3月7日。今天是珍娜的生日。她今天45岁了。我是。我们刚刚为了她的生日去远足了。现在我们坐在曾经是我那间破旧的车库里，我们把它改造成了我的办公室。办公室兼客房兼泳池房兼儿童游戏室。游戏妈。珍娜和我都非常兴奋。这是我们第一次一起大声朗读我们的一些页面。当珍娜朗读时，她先来。我正在吃土豆火鸡卷饼和薯片配莎莎酱，所以我希望那不会令人讨厌。
Well, first of all, Pam always had candy on her desk. And one of my favorite candies, personally, is candy corn. You love candy corn. Sorry, I'm eating. And they would put candy corn in my candy dish the week that we shot Halloween episodes. And the first year they did it, I ate so much of it. And I think the props people were so annoyed with me because they had to keep refilling that dish for continuity. And then I actually got sick. I actually got a stomachache from eating too much
好吧，我只是真的很兴奋以后能听这个并把它转录出来，听听你的薯片声音。我觉得这对我来说会很有趣。它一直给珍娜带来惊喜。好吧，所以我的工作是深入研究万圣节剧集，不仅仅是万圣节剧集，而是办公室里的万圣节总体情况，因为那是一个非常特殊的时期。确实是。我们玩得很开心。我在想为什么。为什么它在办公室的片场是一个如此非常特殊、备受期待的节日？
candy. I was like a child. It's like what our parents tell us. Yeah, don't make you sick. It did, but it was just right there. So I was thinking about besides the candy corn, why did we love it so much? And I thought about it. Our regular wardrobe was so routine. Every character basically had a uniform. Like Dwight had mustard shirts, Pam, with pastel cardigans and pencil skirts. Angela, you were just high-necks gray charcoal I literally have a line where I say I improvised I was so proud of that they were like Amy Adams was like what's your favorite color and I said gray charcoal shades of gray shades of gray Phil is basically just dressed in purple right our tiger print oh no leopard
首先，帕姆的桌上总是有糖果。我个人最喜欢的糖果之一是玉米糖。你喜欢玉米糖。抱歉，我在吃。他们会在我们拍摄万圣节剧集的那个星期把玉米糖放在我的糖果盘里。他们这样做的第一年，我吃了太多。我想道具组对我太恼火了，因为他们为了连戏不得不一直给那个盘子重新填满。然后我真的生病了。我真的因为吃太多而胃痛。
print leopard print animal prints or purple at least Andy got the preppy plaids an interesting belt he always had some real many belts interesting belt and if you think about it our hairstyle never really changed either No, I feel like we just really craved any chance to break out, and Halloween was the chance. Oh, it was a big chance. It was a huge, it wasn't just a slight breakout. It was a huge breakout. It was like the most exciting thing to happen to the wardrobe department, to the hair, makeup department.
我就像个孩子。就像我们的父母对我们说的那样。是的，别吃坏了肚子。确实如此，但它就在那里。所以我一直在想，除了玉米糖，为什么我们那么喜欢它？我想了想。我们日常的戏服太套路了。每个角色基本上都有制服。比如德怀特穿芥末黄衬衫，帕姆穿着柔和色调的开衫和铅笔裙。安吉拉，你总是高领灰色炭灰色。我真的有一句台词说我即兴发挥了，我为此感到无比自豪。他们就像是艾米·亚当斯（Amy Adams）问你最喜欢什么颜色，我说灰色炭灰色，灰色的阴影，灰色的阴影。菲尔基本上只是穿紫色，对吧？我们的虎纹，噢，不，豹。
Everyone was very excited. And, you know, it was equal among genders. I remember Rain getting so excited about his costumes. So sometimes people ask me if we ever had any say and what our characters dressed as for Halloween. And the very simple answer to that is no. Absolutely not. Absolutely not. So many of our costumes were plot related. There was like the joke that you could wear the same white cat costume year after year even when you were pregnant, which is a very funny snarky scene that we have. Or the time that Creed, Dwight and Kevin all dresses the Joker. Or the time when Pam dressed as Charlie Chaplin just to find out she was the only person to dress up in a costume at her new job. That was when she was off at art school. And then she couldn't take off her hat because then she looked like Hitler. So the costume choices were mostly dictated by the story. that the writer wanted to tell.
印花，豹纹，动物印花或者至少是紫色。安迪穿了学院风格子，还有一条有趣的皮带，他总是系着一些真正的迷你皮带，有趣的皮带。如果你想想，我们的发型也从来没有真正改变过。没有，我觉得我们真的很渴望任何突破的机会，而万圣节就是这个机会。噢，这是一个大机会。这是一个巨大的机会，这不仅仅是一个微小的突破。这是一个巨大的突破。这就像是服装部门、发型和化妆部门发生的最令人兴奋的事情。
That happened to be on Halloween. But I feel like there was one exception. Do you know who I'm thinking of? Oh my God. Can I guess? Mindy Kaling? Yes. Mindy Kaling.
每个人都非常兴奋。而且，你知道，这在性别上是平等的。我记得雷恩对他的服装感到非常兴奋。所以有时候人们问我，我们是否对我们的角色在万圣节穿什么有任何发言权。而这个问题的非常简单的答案是，没有。绝对没有。绝对没有。我们的许多服装都与情节有关。比如那个笑话，你一年又一年地穿着同一套白色猫咪服装，甚至当你怀孕的时候，这是我们拍过的一个非常搞笑、刻薄的场景。或者克里德、德怀特和凯文都打扮成小丑的那一次。或者帕姆打扮成查理·卓别林，结果发现自己是新工作单位里唯一一个穿万圣节服装的人的那一次。那是她在艺术学校的时候。然后她摘不下帽子，因为那样她看起来就像希特勒。所以服装的选择主要由编剧想要讲述的故事决定。
Mindy was also on the writing staff. She got to be part of picking her own costume. And she always, well, Mindy loves to dress up. Like she loves to go big, right? Yes, she does. And she had the best costume. She was Carrie Bradshaw. She was Snooky, Katie Perry, and then Leeloo from the Fifth Element.
碰巧发生在万圣节。但我觉得有一个例外。你知道我在想谁吗？天哪。我能猜吗？敏迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）？是的。敏迪·卡灵。
and I have this picture of you and Mindy. You were like a black widow. I took my camera that day. That's a cold open we shot. Yeah. Didn't get used. Yes. And she was,
敏迪也是编剧团队的一员。她得以参与挑选自己的服装。她总是——嗯，敏迪喜欢打扮。就像她喜欢搞大场面一样，对吧？是的，她确实如此。她有最好的服装。她是凯莉·布拉德肖（Carrie Bradshaw）。她是Snooki，凯蒂·佩里（Katy Perry），然后是《第五元素》（The Fifth Element）里的莉露（Leeloo）。
Lilu and like she had a multipass. Lilu Matupas. Lillu Muttipas. You haven't seen the fifth element? Uh-uh. Jenna, this is a great movie and I think it still holds up. I'm just going to say that.
我有一张你和敏迪的照片。你当时就像个黑寡妇。那天我带了相机。那是我们拍的一个冷场开场。是的。没被采用。是的。她当时是。
Lillu Matipas. What does that mean? Are you saying her last name? Are you saying Lelu has a multi-pass? Like she's going to a... She's going to outer space and you have to have this multi-pass. to get on this ship. Like a Metro car?
莉露，而且她有一个多通道通行证（multipass）。莉露·马蒂帕斯。莉露·马蒂帕斯。你没看过《第五元素》吗？呃-uh。珍娜，这是一部很棒的电影，我觉得它现在依然经得起推敲。我只想这么说。
Kind of. Oh, you have to see this. Bruce Willis is in it? I do love Bruce Willis. Chris Tucker's in it. No. But this Leeloo costume was basically white gauze. So much skin.
莉露·马蒂帕斯。那是什么意思？你是在说她的姓吗？你是在说莉露有多通道通行证吗？就像她要去……她要去外太空，你必须有这个多通道通行证。才能上这艘船。就像地铁卡吗？
Yes, well, you have to see it because she's in like this. Oh, God, I don't even know how to explain it. But she is the fifth element. Okay. Lilu. All right. Okay, so I guess Mindy Kaling and I was right. Mindy Kaling.
差不多。噢，你一定要看这个。布鲁斯·威利斯（Bruce Willis）在里面吗？我确实喜欢布鲁斯·威利斯。克里斯·塔克（Chris Tucker）在里面。没有。但这个莉露的服装基本上是白色纱布。露出了好多皮肤。
I want to talk about one of my personal favorite episodes of The Office, which also happens to be our very first Halloween episode. Okay. It aired during season two and was called appropriately Halloween. I cry at the end every time I watch it. So the plot is very simple, if you don't remember. Michael is told that he must fire someone during the month of October due to cutbacks at Dunder Mifflin. But in true Michael fashion, he waits until the very last day of October, which also happens to be Halloween. Greg Daniels wrote this episode, and I remember him telling me that the inspiration for the episode was that he had always wanted to do a story about someone being fired, but from the point of view of the boss rather than the employee. He said,
是的，好吧，你得去看看，因为她穿着这样的衣服。噢，天哪，我甚至不知道该怎么解释。但她就是第五元素。好的。莉露。好吧。好吧，所以我猜是敏迪·卡灵，我猜对了。敏迪·卡灵。
we always see stories of the people being fired, but rarely stories about the person having to do the firing. And I always thought that Greg's decision to set the story on Halloween when everyone is dressed up and excited for an office Halloween party made the whole thing even more delightfully uncomfortable to watch. Oh, so tragic. Like no one wants to get fired when they're dressed up like a clown or something. It's depressing. But the one problem that this plot presented for Greg was that he would actually have to fire someone on the show. And he didn't want to fire any of the core cast members, even though many of the supporting characters at this time were still under weekly contracts. You guys were not considered series regulars yet. Oh, no, not at all. You know how you say you have a
我想谈谈我个人最喜欢的《办公室》剧集之一，它恰好也是我们的第一个万圣节剧集。好的。它在第二季播出，名字很贴切，叫《万圣节》。每次我看的时候，我在结尾都会哭。所以剧情非常简单，如果你不记得了。迈克尔被告知，由于邓德米夫林的预算削减，他必须在10月份解雇一个人。但保持了迈克尔一贯的风格，他一直拖到10月的最后一天，而这一天恰好也是万圣节。格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）写了这一集，我记得他告诉我，这一集的灵感来自于他一直想做一个关于某人被解雇的故事，但不是从员工的角度，而是从老板的角度。他说，
photo of the exact moment you knew we'd be best friends? Yes. I have a photo of the exact moment I was made series regular. And you and I are jumping up and down, giddy, holding hands, jumping up and down, because I got the news while we were on booze cruise. That's when we became series regulars. But this was before Booth's Cruise. Yes. So he could have any of us fired any of you guys, but he didn't want to. But he also didn't want to hire a new person just for one episode, establish them, and fire
我们总是看到关于人们被解雇的故事，但很少看到关于不得不执行解雇的那个人的故事。我一直认为格雷格决定将故事背景设定在万圣节，当每个人都盛装打扮、为办公室万圣节派对兴奋不已时，这让整件事看起来更加令人痛苦地尴尬。噢，太悲剧了。就像没有人想在自己打扮得像个小丑之类的时候被解雇。这太令人沮丧了。但这个情节给格雷格带来的一个问题是，他实际上必须在剧中解雇某人。他不想解雇任何核心演员，尽管当时许多配角仍然受周薪合同的约束。你们当时还不被认为是剧集常规演员。噢，不，完全不是。你知道你是怎么说你有一张。
them because it felt dishonest. Like it felt, he said it felt like cheating. So he had to fire someone we'd already seen on the show. So we had two stand-ins at the time, and maybe we should tell people what a stand-in is. A stand-in is a person who fills in for the actor after the rehearsal of a scene while the crew adjust the light. They walk where the actor would walk or sit or stand where the actor would sit or stand during the scene and the crew figures out where to put the cameras in the light. And then when it's time for the camera to roll, the actors are called back to the set and
你知道我们成为最好朋友的那一刻的照片吗？是的。我有一张我成为剧集常规演员的那一刻的照片。你和我正在上下跳跃，兴奋不已，手拉着手，上下跳跃，因为我在我们参加酒水游轮（booze cruise）的时候得到了这个消息。那是我们成为常规演员的时候。但这发生在酒水游轮之前。是的。所以他可以解雇我们中的任何一个人，你们中的任何一个人，但他不想。但他也不想为了单集雇佣一个新角色、建立他们然后又解雇他们，因为这感觉不诚实。就像它感觉，他说这感觉像是在作弊。所以他不得不解雇一个我们已经在剧中见过的人。所以我们当时有两个替身，也许我们应该告诉大家什么是替身。替身是在场景排练后代替演员的人，当剧组调整灯光时。他们走演员要走的路，或坐在或站在演员要在场景中坐或站的地方，剧组则弄清楚把摄像机和灯光放在哪里。然后当到了摄像机开拍的时候，演员被叫回片场并。
begin shooting the scene. So we had two stand-ins. They were Creed and Devon. And both Creed and Devon had also appeared on camera in the background of some conference room scenes or in the annex by the break room. Maybe they would like cross in the deep background of a scene like they were delivering mail. I remember we have that mail cart that really made sense because we didn't have a male room but whatever but they've never spoken they've been established so that was enough for Greg but then Greg who is the gentlest man had the dilemma of picking who to fire Creed or Devin I can't imagine how that weighed on Greg because he really is just a kind kind-hearted
开始拍摄场景。所以我们有两个替身。他们是克里德和德文。克里德和德文也都曾在某些会议室场景的背景中或休息室旁边的附楼里在摄像机前出现过。也许他们会穿过一个场景的极远背景，就像他们在送信一样。我记得我们有那个邮件车，这真的很有意义，因为我们没有收发室，但不管怎样，但他们从未说过话。他们已经被确立了，所以对格雷格来说这就足够了。但随后，格雷格这个最温和的人，面临着挑选谁被解雇的困境：克里德还是德文？我无法想象这在格雷格心中有多沉重，因为他真的只是一个善良、心地善良的人，这一定把他折磨坏了。所以格雷格和他们两个都谈过，他发现德文刚刚在纽约的一部外百老汇戏剧中获得了一个角色。所以这就是格雷格需要听到的全部。他决定德文将被解雇，既然他有这份工作要去。他有地方可去。而克里德则从我们剧中的一个不说话的替身，变成了一个与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）有五页剧本场景的演员。
person and it just must have erect him so Greg spoke with both of them and he found out that Devon had just been cast in an off-Broadway play in New York. So this was all Greg needed to hear. He decided Devin would be fired since he had this job to go-to. He had something to go-to. And Creed went from being a non-speaking stand-in in our show to getting a five-page scene with Steve Carell.
没有试镜。格雷格从未看过他演戏，直接交给他一张与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔演对手戏的五页剧本。这个场景在粉丝中非常受欢迎，格雷格也非常高兴，是的，他开始为克里德写更多内容，然后克里德最终也成为了剧集的常规演员。是的。这一切都是因为格雷格需要找个人解雇。
No audition. Greg had never seen him act, handed him a five-page scene with Steve Carrell. The scene was so popular with fans, and Greg was so delighted, yeah, that he started writing more stuff for Creed, and then Creed eventually also became a series regular. Yes. And it was all because Greg needed someone to fire.
所以除了这一集是让克里德进入办公室大家庭的剧集之外，它还创造了许多“第一”。这一集是吉姆和帕姆第一次空中击掌的剧集。噢，Jam！Jam空中击掌！这也是帕姆第一次被看到把头发放下，而不是半扎半放，我称之为帕姆鲻鱼头（Pam Mullet）。关于这种发型改变是否被允许，曾有过巨大的争论。它在获得批准之前与制片人和编剧进行了几轮商讨。如果帕姆把头发放下，她会看起来太可爱吗？他们决定尝试一下。
So in addition to this being the episode that launched Creed into the office family, it is responsible for a number of first. This is the episode that features Jim and Pam's first air high five. Aw, Jam! Jam Air High Five! It is also the first time Pam is seen wearing her hair down rather than half up, half down, which I call the Pam Mullet. And it was a huge debate about whether or not this hair change could be allowed. it went several rounds with the producers and writers before being approved. Would Pam look too cute if she wore her hair down? They decided to go for it.
然后你下一次看到帕姆的发型改变是在赌场之夜（Casino Night）。我的意思是，如果我们知道关于发型之类的大量细节，那是因为这些都是巨大的讨论。我们总是希望忠于这些人物的真实性，并且随着剧集成功的增长，不要把他们打扮得太花哨。他们仍然在斯克兰顿的一家纸业公司，尽管剧集越来越受欢迎，我们有点变得，我不知道，就像，更高级了。好吧，服装也是如此。
And then the next time you see a hair change from Pam is Casino Night. I mean, if we know a lot of details about hair and stuff like that, is because these were huge discussions. We just always wanted to stay true to the integrity of who these people were and not as the success of the show grew, like, juzze them up too much. They were still in Scranton in a paper company, even though the show was gaining more popularity and we were sort of becoming a little bit like, I don't know, like fancier. Well, this was true of wardrobe as well.
他们只在我们的角色能够实际负担得起的地方购物。所以如果帕姆必须穿一条牛仔裤，我穿的是从Gap买的牛仔裤。我没有穿一条200美元的设计师牛仔裤。没错。而且我们的服装部门也很棒。你知道，他们确保你的裤子不会太长之类的，但他们不会像大多数电视剧那样为你修改尺寸。在《办公室》之后，我拍了一部名为《你的或我的家人》（Your Family or Mine）的剧，负责服装的女性也曾负责《老友记》（Friends）的服装。那些女性在《老友记》里看起来棒极了。
They only shopped at places that our characters could realistically afford to shop at. So if Pam had to wear a pair of jeans, I wore a pair of jeans from the gap. I did not wear a pair of $200 designer jeans. Right. And also our wardrobe department was amazing. You know, they made sure like your pants weren't too long or things like that, but they did not fit you, like alter things the way most TV shows do. And after the office, I worked on a show called Your Family or Mine, and the women that did the wardrobe also did the wardrobe for friends. And those women looked amazing on friends.
而我这辈子从来没有看起来这么，像帕姆那样，哪怕一次。他们修改了每一个，所有东西。他们修改了，比如你的肩缝在哪里，以及，比如袖口末端，像所有东西都像手套一样合身。是的，大多数电视剧都会根据你的身体裁剪衣服。是的，这就是为什么每个人在电视上看起来都那么棒。他们对我说，你知道普通人走在街上和电视节目中走在街上的人有什么区别吗？
And I have never looked so, bam, like, ever in my life. They altered it every, everything. They altered, like, where your shoulder hymn is and where, like, the end, like, everything fit me like a glove. Yes, most shows tailor clothes to your body. Yeah. And that's why everybody looks so fabulous on TV. They said to me, do you know what's the difference between just a normal person walking down the street and someone walking down the street on a TV show?
而且我一生中从未看起来这么棒，简直绝了。他们改了每一处，所有地方。他们改了肩缝的位置，还有衣长，一切都像为我量身定制的一样。是的，大多数节目都会根据你的身材裁剪衣服。是的。这就是为什么每个人在电视上看起来都那么棒。他们对我说，你知道普通人走在街上和电视节目里的人走在街上有什么区别吗？
And I said what? And they said alterations. It's 100% true. Because most people like figure out how to blow out their hair and put a little bit of makeup on. But having clothes fit you like that and they were blown away because I was like, oh my gosh, look how this fits me. Oh, you're going to take that in? You're going to sew this. And they're like, Angela, have you never had your clothes altered?
我说什么？他们说这是改衣服。这绝对是千真万确的。因为大多数人都会自己吹头发、化点淡妆。但当衣服那样合身时，他们都惊呆了，因为我在想，天哪，看看这衣服多合身。哦，你要把这里收进去吗？你要缝这个。他们就说，安吉拉，你从来没改过衣服吗？
altered on the office. I was like, uh, no. No. Because we had to look realistic for that world. Another thing about Halloween is people dress up as our office characters for Halloween on Halloween, which I love so much. Which is crazy, right? When I get tagged as White and Angela, I love it so much. You are a Halloween costume. Yeah. I also want to say that of all the photos that I get, I think that the most popular, the one I see the most, is the Pam Cat Three Hole Punch Gym. Yeah, that's the one I get the most. I get just myself in an Argyll sweater with usually the girls have their hair in a headband or slick back pony and they're all holding a cat stuffed animal. I get a lot where girls are wearing the white kids.
在办公室里改衣服。我说，呃，没有。没有。因为我们要让那个世界看起来很真实。关于万圣节的另一件事是，人们在万圣节会打扮成我们办公室里的角色，我太喜欢了。这太疯狂了，对吧？当我被标记为白人和安吉拉时，我太喜欢了。你就是一个万圣节服装。是的。我还想说，在我收到的所有照片中，我认为最受欢迎、我看到最多的一张，就是帕姆的猫咪三孔打孔器吉姆。是的，这是我收到最多的。我收到的就是我自己穿着一件阿盖尔毛衣，通常女孩们把头发扎在发带里或梳成清爽的马尾辫，她们都拿着一只猫的毛绒玩具。我收到很多女孩穿着白色衣服的照片。
Another first, this Halloween episode was the first time since our pilot that the creators of the original British series of the office, Stephen Merchant and Ricky Jervais visited our set. Yes. They stayed almost an entire day. one day when we were filming. We were all geeking out. Before they left, I asked for a photo with them and some of the American producers of the show. But I am the only person in the photo who is obviously dressed in a Halloween costume. Do you have it?
另一个第一次是，这个万圣节剧集是自试播集以来，英国原版《办公室》剧集的创作者斯蒂芬·莫昌特和瑞奇·热维斯第一次参观我们的片场。是的。有一天我们拍摄时，他们待了几乎整整一天。我们都兴奋得不得了。在他们离开之前，我请求和他们以及该剧的一些美国制片人合影。但我是照片中唯一一个明显穿着万圣节服装的人。你有这张照片吗？
Yes. You can kind of see, like, Jim has like one circle of his three-hole punch. Yes. When I look at the photo, I like to imagine that I was doing like a school play about a cat and all these people came to see me and I pose for a picture backstage. Yeah, that's backstage at your cat play. At my cat play. Yeah.
有的。你大概能看出来，吉姆身上有三孔打孔器的一个圆圈。是的。当我看着这张照片时，我喜欢想象我当时正在排演一出关于猫的学校话剧，所有这些人都是来看我的，我在后台摆姿势拍照。是的，那是你在猫咪话剧后台。在我的猫咪话剧后台。是的。
Yeah. Here's my one story about Ricky Dervase. So they were on set. We were all kind of nervous about it. And I hadn't really been in scenes yet. But after lunch, I had a talking hedge. And I come through the lunch area and I see Ricky Jervase and I'm introduced to him. Ricky's actually going back to Video Village now because he's going to watch everything from lunch on to the end of day. And you were the first thing he started watching? And I was like, great. And they were like, Angela, you're first up.
是的。这就是我关于瑞奇·热维斯的一个故事。当时他们在片场。我们都有点紧张。而且我还没怎么演过戏。但在午饭后，我有一场采访。我穿过午餐区，看到了瑞奇·热维斯，并被介绍认识了他。瑞奇现在要回视频村了，因为他要从午餐一直看到一天结束。你成了他看的第一个人？然后我说，太棒了。他们说，安吉拉，你是第一个上场的。
And I said, oh, fantastic. And I look to Ricky Jervais and he goes, don't worry, I don't tisk too loudly. And that's what he said to me. That's amazing. For all of these reasons, I love this first Halloween episode. But I especially love the end. And I don't know if you remember the end,
我说，哦，太棒了。我看着瑞奇·热维斯，他说道，别担心，我叹气声音不会太大。这就是他对我说的话。太棒了。出于所有这些原因，我喜欢这第一集万圣节。但我尤其喜欢结局。我不知道你是否还记得结局，
but at the end, Michael hands out candy to little kids and I cry every time. I'm getting choked up thinking about it. I remember there was a big debate over how that final moment should be played out. there was a discussion as to whether or not the kids should be nice to Michael or if they should be annoyed by him because he was going to be cracking jokes while he handed out candy. And the writers and producers also discussed if Steve should be happy or sad while handing out the candy.
但在结局时，迈克尔给小孩子们发糖果，每次我都看哭了。一想到这我都哽咽了。我记得对于最后这个时刻应该如何演绎，曾有过一场大争论。大家讨论孩子们是对迈克尔好，还是应该觉得他烦人，因为他在发糖果时会开玩笑。编剧和制片人们还讨论了史蒂夫在发糖果时应该是高兴还是难过。
It was decided that they would start on the spy shot of Michael looking sad and lonely inside of his house, alone on Halloween night. He's just fired someone. Then you hear the doorbell and when he gets to the door and sees the kids, he lights up, he makes his silly jokes. And the kids just laugh and laugh and are delighted by him. And he makes this connection. I'm crying.
最终决定，他们将从迈克尔在万圣节夜晚独自一人坐在屋里显得伤心和孤独的偷拍镜头开始。他刚刚解雇了某人。然后你听到门铃响了，当他走到门前看到孩子们时，他精神一振，开起了傻气的玩笑。孩子们只是不停地笑，被他逗得很开心。他建立了这种联系。我哭了。
Yeah. And it's just beautiful and kind and heartbreaking. And it's moments like this that make the office so special. We can spend an entire episode laughing at Michael Scott or finding him annoying, but in the end, he will break your heart with his kindness and vulnerability. And his desire to have what we all want, which is just to love and be loved in return. Yes. And that is heartbreaking and so sweet.
是的。这真是太美妙、太善良、太让人心碎了。正是这样的时刻让《办公室》变得如此特别。我们可以花整整一集的时间嘲笑迈克尔·斯科特，或者觉得他很烦人，但最终，他的善良和脆弱会让你心碎。以及他想要得到我们所有人都想要的东西的渴望，那就是去爱并得到爱。是的。这真是让人心碎又无比甜蜜，
and so real, isn't it? It's just like such an honest moment. I think that's what I think Greg Daniels was so great at, and our show is finding these just real life moments that were so honest. And you've got to know firing someone was so hard for Michael because all he wanted to do was be liked. And this dysfunctional office family was truly his family. It was such a great choice to have him go home
而且如此真实，不是吗？这就像是一个如此真诚的时刻。我想这就是格雷格·丹尼尔斯最厉害的地方，我们的节目就是能找到这些如此真诚的现实生活中的时刻。你必须知道，解雇某人对迈克尔来说太难了，因为他唯一想做的就是被人喜欢。而这个功能失调的办公室大家庭真的是他的家。让他回家的选择真是太棒了
and you see why he's so needy at work. Yes. You know. He's so lonely. He's just so lonely. And I loved that the kids delighted in him. And there was this thing that Steve did with his face. He just looked like lit up inside.
然后你就会明白为什么他在工作时需求那么强烈。是的。你知道的。他太孤独了。他只是太孤独了。我喜欢孩子们为他感到高兴。史蒂夫的脸上有一个动作。他看起来就像是从内部亮了起来。
You know, when they laughed, you saw that joy come over Michael. Oh, it was so sweet. If we ever get to do a reunion episode, I just need to see Michael Scott with his kid. Yes. And he's the best dad. His best dad. Yes. And his kid just thinks he.
你知道，当他们笑的时候，你看到那种喜悦涌上了迈克尔的面庞。哦，太甜了。如果我们有机会拍一集重聚剧集，我只想看到迈克尔·斯科特和他的孩子在一起。是的。他是个最好的爸爸。最好的爸爸。是的。而他的孩子只觉得他
is everything. Yeah. Exactly. And him and Holly are just happy. Yeah. It would make me so happy. I would cry. And maybe he still annoys people at work, but he's like the best dad. The best dad. And I think it hit me even harder now that I have kids. Yeah. Because I just know what kids bring to your life. The episode was written by Resident Genius Greg Daniels. It was directed by, do you know, Paul Figue? Oh, Paul Figue. Well, you know, I was going to guess Ken Koppas or Paul Fieg because they're in the early years, that's a good guess. Yeah, and they also, we gave them a lot of the big, like, milestone episodes. During his time on the show, I'm going to give you some fast facts about Paul Feig. He directed 14 episodes of the office, but he also spent an entire season where he was a consulting producer.
是一切。是的。完全正确。他和霍莉也很幸福。是的。这会让我太高兴了。我会哭的。也许他在工作时仍然让人讨厌，但他就像是最好的爸爸。最好的爸爸。我想现在我自己有了孩子，这种感受更加深刻了。是的。因为我深知孩子会给你的生活带来什么。这一集由常驻天才格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧。你知道是谁导演的吗，保罗·菲格？哦，保罗·菲格。好吧，你知道的，我本来要猜肯·卡帕斯或保罗·菲格，因为他们在早期执导过，这是个很好的猜测。是的，而且他们还，我们把许多重大、具有里程碑意义的剧集都交给了他们。在他参演期间，我向你透露一些关于保罗·菲格的快讯。他执导了14集《办公室》，但他还曾有一整季担任顾问制片人。
That's right. And he was there every day on set. When he left, I was like, no, Paul, don't. I felt so safe with him there. It was a dream. He also, I think, hosted the most cast-viewing parties of anyone in his home with his incredible life. Lori. Yes, and their home was beautiful. Beautiful. And it's just so warm and inviting. I loved it. They put out a little like snackety snack in the kitchen and then we would all get our stuff and we would go watch the show together.
没错。他每天都在片场。他离开时，我想，不，保罗，别走。他在那里让我感到非常安全。那真是一场梦。我还认为，他在自己家里和他的了不起的妻子劳里一起举办了最多的剧组观看派对。是的，他们的家非常漂亮。漂亮。而且非常温馨热情。我太喜欢了。他们在厨房里摆了一些小零食，然后我们大家拿着东西一起去看节目。
We did we did that so much. So much and Paul any viewing parties. Paul and Lori are just such great party hosts. Paul is one of the best dressed people you will ever meet in your life. Full suit with tie. I've never not seen him in a suit and his Instagram is all of him in suits with cocktails. You have to see it. because it's very enjoyable. It's very impressive. We're about to deep dive on your feet on Instagram. Don't get freaked out. Also, did you talk about what the crew would do on Friday when it was Paul Feig's episode?
我们经常这样做。经常这样，保罗举办了好多观看派对。保罗和劳里真的是太棒的派对主人了。保罗是你这辈子能见到的最会穿衣的人之一。西装革履，系着领带。我从没见过他穿便服，他的Instagram上全是他穿着西装拿鸡尾酒的照片。你一定要去看看。因为非常有意思。非常令人印象深刻。我们马上要在Instagram上深入了解你的脚了。别被吓到。还有，你聊过保罗·菲格导演的剧集播出时，剧组周五会做什么吗？
They would all wear a tie. Oh, yes. Yeah, it would be Paul Feig Day, suit day, every Friday when Paul Feig directed. And all the crew members, the camera guys, they would all wear ties. Halloween did not end with our Halloween episodes. In order to edit the episodes in time to air during the actual week of Halloween, I mean, we filmed our Halloween episodes, like usually in August, like months before. So every year we got two Halloween celebrations.
他们都会系领带。哦，是的。是的，每当保罗·菲格执导时，每个周五都会是保罗·菲格日、西装日。所有的剧组成员、摄影师，都会系上领带。万圣节并没有随着我们的万圣节剧集而结束。为了剪辑这些剧集，以便在万圣节当周及时播出，我的意思是，我们通常在八月份左右拍摄万圣节剧集，也就是几个月前。所以每年我们都能庆祝两次万圣节。
First was the week that we shot the Halloween episode, but then there was actual Halloween. And during actual Halloween week, our crew would all dress up and we would have a costume parade at lunch. And the crew went all out. Yeah. We would shoot a whole day with them all in costumes and us dressed as our characters. One year, I don't know if you remember this, the wardrobe department dressed as the characters from our show. And I have pictures. dressed as
首先是我们拍摄万圣节剧集的那个星期，然后是真正的万圣节。在真正的万圣节那一周，我们的剧组成员都会盛装打扮，我们在午餐时会举行化装游行。剧组成员们都全力以赴。是的。我们和他们一起拍了一整天，他们都穿着盛装，而我们穿着角色的服装。有一年，我不知道你还记不记得，服装部打扮成了我们剧中的角色。我有照片。打扮成
that is hilarious although this guy was a props guy he wasn't wardrobe but wardrobe dressed as us oh my gosh that's amazing I know that's pretty great
太搞笑了。虽然这家伙是个道具师，他不是服装部的，但服装部打扮成了我们的样子。哦，天哪，这太棒了。我知道，这真的很棒，
because I think something that people say a lot but was very true for us and maybe it's true for them too we were like one big family we were not just the cast it was the crew yes we looked out for one another
因为我觉得人们经常说的一句话，对我们来说非常真实，也许对他们也是如此，我们就像一个大家庭，我们不仅仅是演员，还有剧组成员。是的，我们彼此照顾，
we enjoyed being together this is a story that's near and dear to my heart when my son Weston was one years old I wanted to dress him as a Wimbledon tennis player because I had a little shirt from Wimbledon like a little polo shirt from Wimbledon that had a little logo on it and it just seemed like an easy outfit
我们享受在一起的时光。这是一个对我而言至关重要、铭记在心的故事。当我的儿子韦斯顿一岁时，我想把他打扮成温网网球运动员，因为我有一件温网的小衬衫，就像温网的小Polo衫一样，上面有个小标志，这看起来像是一套简单的服装，
you know the players just wear all white so I had the shirt I put white shorts little white sneakers a little white hat and when Phil Shea the head of our props department heard what I was putting together he arranged for someone to make him an actual
你知道的，运动员们都穿全白。所以我有了这件衬衫，我给他穿上白色短裤、小白鞋、小白帽。当我们的道具部主管菲尔·谢伊听到我在准备什么时，他安排人给他制作了一个真正的
tiny perfectly proportioned tennis racket and bag I know. A real tennis racket. I know. And it was so tiny. Not plastic. It was like out of metal.
一个微型比例完美的网球拍和网球包，我知道。一个真正的网球拍。我知道。而且它太小了。不是塑料的。就像是金属做成的。
It was literally the cutest thing on the planet. It made the whole outfit. And then I sewed a little yellow, squishy ball into his pocket. So it looked like he had a little... Ball coming out of his pocket. Out of his pocket. And it was so sweet. I brought Weston in to work at lunchtime so that he could be part of the parade and I have a picture of it.
这绝对是地球上最可爱的东东。它让整套服装完美无缺。然后我在他的口袋里缝了一个黄色的小海绵球。所以看起来就像他口袋里有个……球从口袋里露出来。从他的口袋里。真是太甜了。我在午饭时间带韦斯顿去上班，这样他就可以参与游行，我还有一张照片。
I have a picture of Weston and Isabelle and Lee. And Weston's in this little outfit. And I was coming across folks. photos and I came across it and I didn't have it in my Halloween photos and I was like why is Weston dressed as a tiny Wimbledon tennis player and then I remember that was Halloween our work days were long but they were not as long as a typical television show no we averaged about 12 hours a day and it usually was something like 6 a.m. to 6 a.m. it was rare to go as late as 7.30 but it did happen
我有一张韦斯顿、伊莎贝尔和李的照片。韦斯顿穿着这套小衣服。我当时在看照片，偶然看到了它，我的万圣节照片里居然没有它，当时我就想，为什么韦斯顿打扮得像个小温布尔登网球运动员？然后我想起那是万圣节，我们的工作日很长，但没有典型电视剧那么长。不，我们平均每天大约12小时，通常是从早上6点到晚上6点，很少有工作到晚上7点半的，但确实发生过
occasionally yeah but it never happened on Halloween we were always wrapped early always and I think it's because because so many of our crew members had families with young kids and the producers wanted to make sure that everyone was home in time to celebrate with their families. That's right. And you know, Greg himself is a very big family man. I think that those things are important. They were important to him. And I think when you're on a show where your showrunner, creator, has a family, they just go into it thinking about people's families. I always felt that way. I felt like they knew when I went to them when I had Isabel. and I was going to be bringing her to set. I felt like I could go and have a conversation
偶尔会，是的，但万圣节那天从没发生过，我们总是很早就收工，总是这样。我想这是因为，我们的很多剧组人员都有带着幼小孩童的家庭，制作人们想确保每个人都能及时回家与家人庆祝。没错。而且你知道，格雷格本人也是个非常重视家庭的人。我认为这些事情很重要。这对他是很重要的。我觉得当你在一个运作人、创始人有家庭的剧组里时，他们自然而然就会考虑到员工的家庭。我一直都有这种感觉。我觉得他们知道当我有了伊莎贝尔后去找他们
and they would help make it work. I know that it was very important to Steve that he'd be home for dinner with his family every night. Yes. He would come in first thing in the morning, 5.30, 6 a.m. so that he could be finished by 5.30 at night. And then some of the people who didn't have kids would stay later and then work to that 6, 6.30 time frame happily,
他们会帮忙让事情顺利进行。我知道史蒂夫非常重视每天晚上能回家和家人共进晚餐。是的。他一大早5点半、6点就来上班，这样他晚上5点半就能完工。然后有些没有孩子的员工就会晚点离开，高高兴兴地工作到6点、6点半左右,
you know, for him. In fact, there were a lot of younger people who preferred coming in at 8 a.m. And working later. He did not want to come in at 5.3. But once you have kids, you're awake anyway. Yeah. So you don't want to miss bedtime.
你知道的，为了他。事实上，有很多年轻人更愿意早上8点来上班，然后工作到很晚。他可不想5点半就来。但一旦你有了孩子，反正你也是醒着的。是的。所以你不想错过睡觉时间。
You don't want to miss that dinner in bedtime. And it can be made to work if the people who are in charge make it work. And it happened on Halloween. Also, every year Matt Sone, who was one of our camera operators, and then later he became our director of photography and even directed some episodes, he would throw a party at his house after work for everyone in their families. and he lived in this great neighborhood for trick-or-treating. And we'd show up and he would have these little tables that had crafts for the kids.
你不想错过晚餐和睡觉时间。如果负责人愿意让它顺利运作，事情是可以做到的。万圣节的时候也是如此。还有，每年我们的摄像师之一马特·索恩——后来他成了我们的摄影指导，甚至导演过几集——都会在下班后在家里为每个人和他们的家人举办派对。他住在一个非常适合不给糖就捣蛋的社区里。我们去了之后，他会准备一些放了给孩子们做手工的小桌子。
Oh, it was so cute. They're like front room of their house, had little low tables with little chairs. Yes. It was like kid paradise over there. Little stickers, projects. You could make a little pumpkin. Uh-huh. And then food, they'd order pizza.
噢，太可爱了。就像他们家的前厅，有矮桌子和小椅子。是的。那简直是孩子们的乐园。小贴纸、手工艺品。你可以做一个小南瓜。嗯哼。然后是食物，他们会点披萨。
And then we'd just go out and canvas the neighborhood. And even cast members without kids would come. I know BJ Novak used to go over and hand out candy. Yeah. Because someone had to man the door, right? If everybody leaves, one has to be their hand of a candy. And BJ was like, I'll do it.
然后我们就会出去在社区里挨家挨户要糖。甚至没有孩子的演员也会来。我知道BJ·诺瓦克经常过去发糖。是的。因为总得有人守门吧？如果所有人都走了，总得有人在那儿发糖。BJ就说，我来吧。
I'll never forget one of the years we went, Isabel was Tinkerbell. And she was so excited when she rang the door that people gave her candy. She couldn't believe it. She was like, what is happening? But it was really sweet that we all did that. Even though we'd spent all day working together,
我永远不会忘记我们去的那几年里，伊莎贝尔打扮成小叮当。当她按门铃人们给她糖果时，她兴奋极了。她简直不敢相信。她当时想，发生什么事了？但我们所有人一起做这件事真的很温馨。尽管我们一整天都在一起工作，
we still shared these occasions with one another. It was really sweet. I had this, like, a professor in college. I'm going to get really nerdy for a second. And he was my creative writing professor. and he used to say, you know, what's a pleasure to do is a pleasure to experience. So if you're writing and you love what you're writing, I'm going to love reading it. And I felt that way about the office.
我们依然互相分享这些时刻。真的很温馨。我在大学里有一位这样的教授。我要变得很有书呆子气了。他曾是我的创意写作教授，他经常说，做起来快乐的事，体验起来也是快乐的。所以如果你在写作，并且热爱你写的东西，我也会喜欢阅读它。我对办公室也有这种感觉。
We so loved what we were doing that I think it comes through. I think we cared a lot for each other. We were very invested in each other's lives. And I think now the show still resonates because when you watch that, you feel it. We were genuinely connected. Yeah, and we still are. We still are. Yeah.
我们太热爱我们所做的事情了，我想这种情感是能穿透屏幕的。我觉得我们非常关心彼此。我们都对彼此的生活投入了极大的热情。而且我认为这部剧现在依然能引起共鸣，因为当你观看时，你能感受到这一点。我们有着真诚的联系。是的，我们现在依然如此。我们依然如此。是的。
That was our Halloween. BFF. Air high five. Air high five. Boom. Well, that was so crazy for me to listen to you after all these years. Isn't that wild? I mean, it was your 45th birthday?
那就是我们的万圣节。闺蜜。隔空击掌。隔空击掌。砰。哇，时隔多年听你这么说，对我来说真是太疯狂了。是不是很疯狂？我是说，那是你的45岁生日吗？
Yeah. We had just gone for a hike. And then we were having lunch. I'm so sorry, you guys. I was eating a turkey wrap. I apologize. Because I know you have written in. You don't like us to eat on the podcast.
对。我们刚去徒步旅行。然后我们在吃午饭。非常抱歉，伙计们。我当时在吃火烤鸡肉卷。我道歉。因为我知道你们写信来过。你们不喜欢我们在播客里吃东西。
But I didn't know I was podcasting at the time. I just was. I was having an afternoon with my best friend. I feel like I talked really fast. You think so? A little bit. Yeah, but I also, by the way, think it's very funny that I brought a document. I know.
但我当时并不知道我在录播客。我只是在过日子。我正在和我的好朋友共度一个下午。我觉得我语速好快。你这么觉得？有一点。对，但顺便说一句，我也觉得我带了一份文件这件事非常搞笑。我懂。
You were so organized already. From the beginning. And you were so relaxed. It's like, we're all there. Even from the very beginning, we're all there. It is funny to me, though, that even though we were there to talk about Halloween, we did have the sidebar banter. like me asking you about the fifth element and you hadn't seen it. Have you seen it?
你当时就已经这么有条理了。从一开始就是。而且你那么放松。就像是，我们都在那儿。甚至从一开始，我们就都在那儿。不过我觉得很有趣的是，尽管我们是去谈论万圣节的，我们还是有一些题外话。比如我问你关于《第五元素》的事，而你还没看。你看过吗？
You know, I think I've seen parts of it, but I would do it as a rewatch. Really? I would break it down. I would if you're interested. Yeah. I would take it on. Oh my gosh. Sam Cassie, have you seen the fifth element?
你知道的，我想我看过其中的一些片段，但我愿意重新看一遍。真的吗？我会把它剖析一下。如果你有兴趣的话，我会的。是的。我会接下这个任务。噢天哪。萨姆·卡西，你看过《第五元素》吗？
Oh yeah, many times. I mean, that's a good one, don't you think, Sam? Yeah, I think that'd be a good watch for Jenna. Okay. I'll do it. It's sci-fi-e, right? But doesn't it also have a little... It's funny, too.
哦，是的，看很多次了。我是说，这是一部不错的电影，你不觉得吗，萨姆？是的，我觉得对珍娜来说这是一部值得一看的电影。好的。我去看。这是科幻片吧？但它是不是也有一点……也挺搞笑的。
It's in space. I think that qualifies. Anything that's in space. Yes. Okay. All right. I don't mind space. Okay.
它在太空中。我觉得这算数。任何在太空中的东西。是的。好吧。好吧。我不介意太空。好吧。
I watched Fifth Element when I was a kid, so I don't really remember anything. But I want to point out that it is a film from 1997, like The Edge. So I think Office Ladies has a 1997 theme going on. All right. Yeah. Maybe we need to watch it. Well, listen, we hope you enjoyed that. Thank you so much for writing.
我小时候看过《第五元素》，所以我真的什么都不记得了。但我想指出，这是一部1997年的电影，就像《边缘生死恋》一样。所以我觉得《办公室女士》有一个1997年的主题。好的。是的。也许我们需要看一下。好吧，听着，我们希望你们喜欢这个。非常感谢你们来信，
in, sending in your questions and comments. Carol, Angelo, thank you so much for sharing about the behind the scenes of the web episodes at NBC. And yeah, I can't wait to see what you guys thought of our pilot episode. We'll see you next week. Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
发来你们的问题和评论。卡洛尔、安杰洛，非常感谢你们分享NBC网络剧集背后的故事。是的，我等不及想知道你们对我们的试播集有什么看法了。我们下周见。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安杰拉·金西制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate a producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Wyce-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audyssey的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-维斯伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。